we're rolling okay so
just so you guys know before the podcast
opens where we like just wanted yeah
take a drink of your cup full of ice
that is so noisy and shake it around
while i'm talking
emily shake around silent
emily's literally here
that's not what happened no one heard
that that's not what happened no one
heard ice shaking in there
yeah are you that you're thirsty you're
that dude
i've never seen you drink water you only
drink water when you're not getting the
attention you need this is coke
that's right i what was i and
no one else heard it
the man with headphones on his ears did
not hear it yeah okay
and he's a pilot
so triggered um
i
would like to let you guys know how the
sausage is made
um i think they can tell
we it never gets made it never gets
certain
it's undercooked
i'm starving
we bank a podcast because we get these
amazing guests that are so hard to book
and we sometimes have to
you know do the rigmarole to schedule
them early and later and then sometimes
i say emily like oh remind me what the
podcast was like the tone of it right so
that uh when i do an intro because
everyone wants intros they want context
like oh natasha legere is on you've seen
her and he's just not that into you shit
her tv show broke on cbs i need
sometimes a little refresher because
emily will listen to it and cut out the
parts right um so i can keep my jaw yeah
so emily so cut out the parts where i
say chinese finger trap over and over
again
so i'm like trash and that's fighting
about what i am allowed to say what i'm
not allowed to say so sh so then i go
like oh just give me a quick refresher
and then just now her refresher was
like as if i had dementia
and it's hard to tell with you sometimes
i was so insulted you were like okay so
you sat down with the natasha
um
natasha's female comedian you've known
her for 15 years was like what is
happening
guys
you were like and you gave her some
presents at the beginning
no i remember the holidays right now do
you remember the holidays
i was there emily i do okay well it's
confusing for someone to ask to be
reminded of what happened and then you
remind them and then they get mad at you
for reminding them i'm just saying
do you think i'm a you do treat me like
i'm a vegetable okay but sometimes you
like that yeah a radish i mean honestly
well no that's the vegetable you just
leave me alone
oh good one she doesn't eat vegetables
i'm saying she does only eat croissants
with chocolate okay
okay
sorry emily you're the only person i
know that you eat like the diet of a
parisian child
i'm doing a cookie cake yeah so it's
it's not even like a bagel like i'm like
are you eating a cake pop for the way
that i eat my body is phenomenal correct
for what i eat correct
and operative word boo
and so
wow
whoa
we are coming in hot today look at you
and your face company
oh my god do you want to talk about
something really yeah
somebody said do this on your own
somebody says i'm out of here emily
changed her flag to not go see her
family four weeks before thanksgiving
and she is on one
she's flying high on not flying i like
it in this conversation you think emily
is the one who's on one
haven't said anything and you're like
you are on wall i needed
the point is
natasha legere was on the podcast who i
am
obsessed with
i was
afraid of asking her to come in the
podcast because i didn't want her to
hate me
um i've loved her for so long we had a
dazzling chat i laughed so hard and this
one that i cried like i was crying in
the corner over there i was crying in
the corner and again that's
the brand i'm trying to change but
are you trying to let me fly
um you're eating a plate of meat and
vegeta like potatoes sitting a fucking
podcast open
oh i'm sorry i'm eating a well-balanced
meal sounds like you're counting
[Applause]
no wonder you go home somehow
is that a kind of pastry i'm not aware
of i know is there chocolate
i hope it doesn't have chocolate
i don't know that is there's something
wrong with it does it have some meringue
um i don't even like meringue so tell me
about um
what is what are we doing right now the
natasha legero
let everyone know she's um a brilliant
comedian they have the uh she has a
podcast with her husband
natasha is
the aficionado on all things funny
stylish
and commitment she has she is a
uh has a a plus in monogamy commitment
and marriage wow makes a marriage work
incredibly work
it's a business they're like the will
and jada of comedy oh yeah you know yeah
and we're like the rocky i'm bowling
i'm natasha
um she's you're bored
the crack rock and bully
she is so
funny so fuck like so quick you know
what's weird about i'm a fan of nintendo
i'm actually a fan of natasha
um
you guys talked about she has a very
high uterus rating her uterus was rated
very highly by her doctor oh you didn't
remember that did you grandma
wiki uterus
um you guys talked about your morning
radio show that was really funny like
your experience on com promoting your
shows on morning radio this is just a
preview of the podcast oh no i'm just
giving you a comment you know what i'm
fine watch it
you know what fine watch it let's google
it i love that on december 3rd i'm going
to be in boise oh god
the egyptian theater
don't i wonder if that's gonna get
canceled calling things egyptian
sorry i am
deep throating a steak
seattle we're going to we have a very
special surprise for seattle is going to
be crazy because this show sold out so
fast and they didn't even know about the
surprise yet i have i just so much
for those of you watching that
i do have um
food in the corner of my mouth i know my
face changes enough as it is it's
probably confusing but
it now looks even more swollen that's
not
it's not a facelift it's food
um seattle december 4th
first show sold out second show
tickets let's do it go get them december
uh we're going to cleveland agura
theater
if you're agoraphobic maybe don't come
december 10th cleveland ohio and then
chicago
chicago illinois
um
vic theater i love this theater so much
and i chose to do the vic theater
because i remember
performing there at the some comedy
festival ages ago and i just like it's
like it's tight and i want to shoot a
special there i wish i wish i was
shooting my special um
on december 11th
but i don't know um all the jokes about
me being in a relationship around i
don't know if they work or not because
i'm not sure if i'm in a relationship so
i have to figure that out first so we're
going to push we're going to shoot the
special this is the promo we're going to
do 20 22.
um
and so
oh
please don't choke
and
um whitneycomings.com nashville and then
december are you farting i know it's
such jesus
don't fart your child your don't fart
your
your meringue just
getting in the way of the smacking
and then
honestly if we
keep watching
i like weird silences
here's what i was
waiting to say is that we are doing a
christmas episode
and it's going to be just us because i
mean who wouldn't want it you can tell
how great this is going to happen for
for two hours straight
questions advice look i have i have i'm
bad at a lot of things
advice about what
take me seriously i've literally just
missed my uh finger trying to make a v a
very serious point and so listen to me
when i say
[Laughter]
ethel has ever been
um
advice about going home for the holidays
family that is where i shine
okay i know i am incredibly shiny on
camera at all times because i leave
that's a choice yeah i lasered my face
off and um all the hair is gone and i
covered in grapeseed oil constantly um
because of ocd in my childhood but i
want to hear from you you can text
818-239-7527
you can leave us voicemails i feel like
i shouldn't be doing this okay leave us
voicemails 818-538-9940
college email us videos and stuff good
for you fans at gmail.com now now i
everyone makes fun of the fact that i
have so many people working for me with
me tim dillon no one checks these i'm
going to start just doing it myself
because no everyone here refuses
i am on community.com every day are you
just just to check in when was the last
time you looked at an email period
that's actually a very good point
we would love to see you log into the
email that would be a real treat oh
sorry the same person that said one
person you what person i can't log into
an email what was this shortcut
email because let me tell you why i
don't wanna
and i ain't gonna okay no really i can't
do it um i'm really doing other stuff
i'm just saying and then benton will
just pick the worst ones possible be
like all your fans are just perverts
emily are they are they not bad
i we you are bad okay all right you
focus on the bad ones because they all
are they're nice
they're they're not bringing their a
game
i would like to put out an all call we
will do it more we just need more more
more content stop calling and breathing
into the phone so it's not me it's you
any of you normally yeah i heard them
in a good way like
just give us some more stuff to work
with
but same people don't leave voicemails
okay well now we're offending everyone
so uh like and subscribe
here's the thing if you don't have
anything to say don't call in
you know what i think i'll just start
writing the emails and have things to
say have jobs and lives and don't have
time to call it i'm sure we'll hear
about in the comments of this so uh
looking forward to that but no one
nobody who doesn't breathe in the phone
would ever call a podcast
so
just you know what give it a try you're
not someone that normally calls in for
stuff like that believe that somebody
who would call into a comedian's podcast
for advice is weird it's like what no
i'm okay with that being said please
don't call me
how come when i checked the voicemails
on a gmail for a podcast that a female
comedian shoots out for a while
but i checked the malcolm they're not
all these smart cute lawyers that have
their shit together i see other people's
fans leave videos that are coherent
who so many who name a podcast name uh
you this is your you're the one that did
this i didn't there's no part of me that
said you know we should do have family
that's what i really want to do i want
to hear from the phones i want to hear
their voicemail i do want to hear from
them me too but i want to hear it
coherently from them okay but then go
hear people that speak coherently so
you're saying all your fans are
ding-dongs
i'm just
i think most people do it when they're
drunk or on nyquil or dayquil or a mix
of both i don't think that you're like
i think that sane people do it and like
toy i'm like
i think it's a last ditch
big swing hail mary i think it's a low
point in someone's life i think that's
right i just agree
we meet a lot of people on tour and i
think they're not at their best when
they call in you know what i just said
you should leave like a physic like a
kleenex box that's emptied out for
people to leave questions comments at
the front of this
box
like a comment diorama should we use all
the kleenex first
no
okay throw them away
write it on the kleenex
i just gave myself a task so that's
great i felt a lot better about it until
we started touring and now we're meeting
these people and they're so elegant and
so smart and they say nice things
and they like have when they ask really
great questions and like
sometimes you go home and you mix
benadryl with zima
things go aside
ways
that's all that being said prove us
wrong
call in we can't talk like this for two
hours we need you guys to call me on
chris's episode or
we'll all kill each other so
call in you need help with your family
we know how to navigate the city you
could never kill me you know what big
shout out
your pill container
i know but how emily what would you do
you couldn't do it
icicle
and then the evidence would grow
why do you have to be elsa at all times
like
let it go it wouldn't it be cute if the
fans if the fans wrote in like uh like
like what they went for
santa
wouldn't it be cool if someone on this
staff checked the emails okay again we
do we have so many to check i don't know
why we're trying to add more
this is obviously important
you should take it to whitney so she has
to check
i do i respond
she does i do she does i respond
personally because everyone here is just
too busy
oh did you want us to respond to your
text messages now
i mean because that would be bad no
i want you to check the voicemails and
the emails so that we're connecting with
our fans and putting them in the opens
we do
do ya
okay they just get pushed for other
stuff like what do you do on all these
five-hour flights home to see your
family okay that's when i get my sleep
in
right
got it because it does feel like you i
don't like everything about crows but
nothing about the fan voicemails every
time i see you you know more about crows
than you did the last time but none of
the fan voicemails are emails which you
think we do all day
yeah
what do you think complain about health
insurance
[Applause]
i need to call kelly
that was too weird to cut that that was
never cutting all of that
what do you think we do
that is funny i don't know why we're
doing an airing of the grievances
are you festivus is jerry stiller
he's dead i'm so happy i have my legs
see you soon chicagi
if i haven't killed her
you can't i swear
in california
that's a good one
okay well now you know what to leave us
voicemails about it's a it's a real
cockeyed plan
where someone's never she'll kill
herself before you ever get there
again not a burn
today when i showed up again
thank you
again great job mike again again
yeah
one point emily oh my god jesus
today when i showed up at 8 am i showed
up and i would open the door and there
were open bottles of tea on all the
stairs like like like this
wait what are you talking about when i
came in today on the stairs the whole
way up though thing she had open bottles
of drinks on different stairs like i was
like
great contribution thank you for that
you're welcome did you want to talk more
about your family i didn't bring out my
phone we're done oh i'm done
enjoy natasha
[Music]
this is uh just to give you a taste of
what this podcast is gonna be like
natasha lagero is here
and no one will call me out on my ship
faster than this one do you see i got
you a pillow oh that's so that like i
picture that being the vibe you got me
this yes that's so nice this actually
matches my the living room wallpaper i
was gonna take it to me but i have like
a lodge and this is those in your home
somehow whitney that's so nice i got you
a couple things that well i mean a lot
of it's just why are you so much that
you can wear it's actually kind of
annoying oh well this is something that
i
this is can i tell you something
you're the only person i feel like this
is rude you're like i think you're ready
for this natasha
have you seen sunset boulevard
you know the aged woman who can't go out
in the sun anymore you're trying to tell
me that you don't love that hat well i
need to see it but
are you sure it definitely seems like a
lot are you trying to tell me that this
is not made for you like getting your
bougainvillea
uh or your rutabaga no i like it you
know what it is it feels very young
it's it's a very new fashionable brand
but i think it's very like old on
purpose no i like it it's almost like um
you know like when lucille ball needed
to go out and like um get radishes for
the bit yeah when she needed to go do a
bit oh no you know what it is remember
when mommy dearest was like chopping the
roses down like if she did it in the
daytime this is what do you have one
wire hanger in your home
i don't exactly
so
you although i did do it to my child
then no more wire hangers as a joke like
and i kind of crossed my eyes and she
was just like mommy that's awful don't
do that or should i just keep this on no
this is for you when you're like thank
you whitney it was it's really nice i
feel like you're camping a lot i'll wear
this to six flags
i'll wear this to legoland next week
wear that for when you need to audition
for it'll look great with a men's
spin-off yeah
wait and there's one more thing in there
that is like whitney so natasha this is
so nice of you i really enjoy getting
gifts for guests
i feel like you have you need a you need
a family you have too much time on your
hands no i i i
tried that whitney wait no that's for
your child shit sorry and i need to put
i needed to glue it that's not for you
that's for your daughter how dare you
okay okay you're gonna give that wait do
you give all your guests presents well
no yes but you are a special person i've
known i mean this is very really good on
me but this is the kind of stuff that i
i can't buy for anyone else to be honest
um my daughter will love this oh it's so
cute isn't that cute if there's a bun
you can just put it on the bun oh you
put this yeah you put a bun and then you
put that on it cute can i borrow it from
my daughter that is for your child
if i ever see you in that i will
write your daughter letter and just say
this was meant for you no there's one
more thing that's for your daughter this
is the this is this whitney this is too
much
okay all right but no it's very nice
thank you all right this one too no it's
there's one more thing that's in here so
natasha okay okay okay careful
careful
like this is important because i feel
like
this this is so cute whitney i love it
this is a very delicate um like are you
sure this isn't for my child
you're like one of the most fun people
to shop for
uh well you should tell that to my
husband because he hasn't given me a
present in five years although that's
not true i told him for our anniversary
i was like um you know you didn't get me
something the past
several years and this hand is very
empty so he did get me an opal because
the
opal is our our anniversary's birthstone
well actually wasn't moshe's idea our
the the woman who made it rachel lauren
she has a company called lauren stewart
and she it was her idea yeah she's very
creative yeah i love that you like have
a gold person well i mean i have a
friend who
i've known forever and she started a
goal business before she became a thing
yeah she used to be an executive at fox
we get it you've had holding deals
we get it so couple things don't know
where to start uh your podcast is a
raging success you take advice from
listeners you play people's like deepest
darkest secrets um i
need
the
orgasming from the belly button through
line to stop but like i am so wait you
listen to our podcast too listen to your
podcast
i like you
i'm a fan of you i'm like wait why are
you getting me things why are you giving
me presents so suspicious this is
amazing i mean this is a comedian it's
so toxic it's just so like hard to
process that anything is uh real but no
i know it's great when people leave
their secrets because i do feel like
just by get telling someone a secret it
just kind of like well yeah it's like
therapy you can have grace i mean that's
the basis of all 12-step programs as you
tell your deepest darkest secrets no
one's freaked out because they've all
thought the same thing and then you get
to go oh i'm not terminally unique i
don't need to have all the shame and i
don't need to go like do ketamine or
whatever you know so it's like my
therapist didn't tell me that but
yeah well you don't have a lot of deep
dark secrets as my guest you're very um
have a very uh uh
authentic relationship with the truth in
reality you're not someone that's
delusional that's nice yeah
as someone that like famously wears like
like elbow high gloves on stage and for
you're not delusional you're one of the
most grounded people i know and i know
that sounds a little bit crazy because
you have such a uh sort of big stage
presence well you know that's another
problem with having a kit thank you
that's nice but i do think that when you
have a kid like i just feel like i don't
i just want to
be around for for that for her right
i mean it so i i guess it took away a
lot of my um ambition
i want to talk about
the child and all and you as a mother
which makes you grounded in a second but
this is my child this show um so i would
like to just wrap up the the here's the
thing that annoys me about the belly
button there's been a uh there was a
caller that said that when they put
their finger in their belly button they
climaxed very intensely and then someone
else called and said that happens to me
too well i was so bummed because of
course i put my finger my belly button
like immediately and it does
it
it does feel
weird
like did you you had never done that
before i mean i'd like to clean like
lint out or you know something like that
but no i hadn't
molested my belly button before and i
don't you feel like a little bit of a
sexual thing
to your pelvis like it is connected
somehow that feels wrong to me it feels
uh morally wrong
well you know it's uh it's not something
i've ever done but i did like try it
when she said but you've just felt i
just feel there are nerve endings that
are
very raw i can't explain people are
fucking bored whitney so bad
and then the relationship advice stuff
is like super fascinating to me and i
love that you and your husband tend to
give slightly different
i mean you have like a perfectly
balanced take on it um which i really
appreciate but you're like a savage with
advice so i did ask the internet for a
couple
questions let's see if we got any good
ones
um
uh i am the breadwinner and my man
instinctually doesn't like it get a
divorce
okay no go on legalzoom legalzoom.org
how can i find a girl to date that can
overlook my disability and just see me
as a person who's not disabled oh wait
that's the guy
that a guy just asked that yeah oh it's
a guy okay he's the breadwinner well
that's a separate person
no those are two separate people
can you start over with me the first one
you answered it so swiftly together you
moved on yeah i moved around no no no no
no i didn't mean to let's let's say
advice i thought that was great advice
it was a woman saying she was the
breadwinner yes okay
let's hear the whole thing from meg meg
i'm about to be the breadwinner and my
man instinctually doesn't like it
oh yeah get a divorce here's what i'll
say or let him use that to his advantage
in my experience when you start making
more money than the guy or are making
more money than the guy he feels
insecure and that drives him to be more
ambitious or to
compensate in other ways listen it
totally depends on the guy like i
purposely married moshe because he
i could tell like
got like he got turned on when i was on
stage or working or doing things or
getting attention he liked it he it made
him happy that i was
happy in
you know in the spotlight and i get
confused because sorry i'm sorry
but you have to you have to you have to
find someone like that who's really into
having
a woman who's successful and here's what
i'll say
when i goes to these like i know i'm
going to a stereotypical place but it's
like all i hear is like women are gold
diggers and like women just want to use
this for our money and then when a woman
has money it's like well now i'm
emasculated by the fact that like which
is it do you know what i'm saying so
that's it it is it's the guy the guy you
know and also moshe told me this is why
i decided to marry him actually he was
like
something happened we were dating and i
was like oh can i talk about that on
stage and he was like oh just so you
know you can always make fun of me on
stage i don't care at all and i was like
oh cool just as long as you say my
instagram handle um but but i think a
lot of people like i've gotten in fights
with ex-boyfriends because like they're
like i don't want you that's private
information and you know he just didn't
he just let it all kind of roll off of
him and i think that's that for me that
was really important one of my favorite
moments in my life
as a person in this field was you at
mbar this was probably 15 years ago you
were on stage and you had torn one of
your headshots in half
and you had your jokes on the back of it
and you were reading your jokes off of a
headshot that's funny i should do that
again and then you went and there were
like very few people in the audience it
was like one of those odd like weird
tuesday shows or something
and you were killing of course but you
were like all right i'm trying to figure
out why did i bring a date here he's
just watching me bomb on stage
really see i have no memory of any any
of that i remember mbar do you know that
i still say thank you so much well we
started comedy together i think yeah you
had you were already like
i started in 2002
yes i started like 2004 yes so you you
were already like
like known and sort of on lineups and
stuff like that did you know that we had
a show together me and you yeah me you
and melinda hill we had a show together
in atwater village what was it called i
don't remember
i was trying to find it it was like we
would kind of book it it was like
outside at a cafe it wasn't an embar we
were social distancing before anyone we
were we had four people six feet apart
at 4 pm
we had a show me and you and melinda in
the day
it was at like sunday at like six like
six to nine
you could tell me anything also i
remember one time we were at a
show on melrose that was like a greek
restaurant and there was like a side
room like a lot of shows were at like
rooms remember there was like a was it
chucklemonkey.com it was like a website
that had like bliss cafe and miyagi's
like all these like random shows at rush
we did comedy at restaurants
no it's all coming back to me for a
while and it was there wasn't even a
stage it was like calm we were doing
comedy for comics for the most part at
that time and this was a show
and you were working on a premise about
like how guys like fist bump i hate that
you were literally just like still hey
what is this and you were just like
hated this bumping why why do i have to
do that
that's like a thing i'm supposed to do
now it was so funny to say hi to my
agent huh you're like but you're like in
a fur coat like what is this
but you know what now i kind of
appreciate it i know i was gonna say you
were waiting
this this is pumped up i've come full
circle i'm like ahead of its time i will
maybe touch your knuckle with my knuckle
i always tell people whenever your name
comes up i'm like she has one of my
favorite jokes ever it's not even a it's
just a kind of a sentence remember when
you would go you know what's weird
babies have skeletons
oh yeah i really didn't want to have a
baby for a long time
i was like very against it so like a lot
of my
jokes were about how i was never gonna
have a baby yes so i haven't i haven't
quite
reconciled at all do you think on some
level the things we protest the most are
inevitable like we have to protest it
because we know that it's imminent in
some way
i mean i didn't really i i
definitely was a situational breeder you
know like if the situation were right
maybe i would consider having a child
where i have friends who are my age who
are like i'm gonna hire a surrogate i'm
gonna do it i'm gonna do it on my own if
i don't have a man i don't care like i
am i'm just i was not that i was and
then when i met moshe i was like oh i
bet he'd be a good dad and then i had
like frozen my eggs on a whim
just to let your ex the same time i did
because of a conversation that we had on
the set some woman told us to okay we
were on the set of uh a movie called
this by the way a lot of moments we've
had together are like seminal moments in
my life and it's so i'm like i don't
totally forget
that belonged to my great grandmother um
no a lot of like very significant
moments like you it actually
works
are you allowed to steal from your it's
your child you can take it whatever's
hers is yours um we were on the set of a
movie called this means war with chelsea
handler that's right and we were in
outtakes that never
were taken out right
we like went in so it was reese
witherspoon
spoon and it was like mick g was
directing or something and then we were
just like outside at some restaurant
like in mini skirts like improvising
and i think it was in like the credits
or something
and we were in a trailer with jenny
slate
uh
who was getting married or something at
the time and
dana fox who was the writer of the movie
and dana fox we were this i remember was
just like you need a freezer i mean i
think she's since had maybe three kids
or something but she was like
talking about her fertility like we've
just met her and i know what it's like
is when you're going through something
and you're just like need to pass on
information that it's totally not
being asked for like she just and it was
like i was like what is what's happening
why is she like i'm young i don't need
to worry about this or whatever and then
i froze my eggs like two months later
because of that conversation
yeah i think that it was like people
just kept saying it and i was like well
you know you never know what if i might
want that it's for insurance it's not
yeah necessary if you can afford it like
i saved up and you know i would tell
someone now doing excited at 37 which i
think is like the definite cut off and i
did it and then i didn't have my baby
till 42 but um and and also you can
carry the kid until you're like like
when they say janet jackson just had a
baby like 45 or something or 55 oh wow
that's not her egg
got it a donor egg probably and i think
it does give people false hope although
i don't know maybe it's can you imagine
being janet jackson
but you're you're not being able to use
your eggs like not a bummer right i know
well maybe she did i don't know but i do
think a lot of times women their uterus
stays good until you're like in your 50s
you know
so uh so yeah oh but one thing i will
say if anyone's listening who's thinking
about doing this like i didn't
understand it at the time because it was
very new technology yeah you know and
they were like
oh you you have 10 eggs and i was like
oh well i only want one kid so that's
plenty please stop i don't want to do
another round but like you really should
do more than one round because i had 10
eggs
then they unfroze them then they turned
them into embryos six of them died then
the embryos got tested there was one
and i no there was two i stuck one up me
it died immediately and then the last
one made my kid right so
you know when i was 42. so i just think
did you freeze embryos or you no i froze
eggs added the sperm to the frozen egg
yeah and that's how they all died
well because it's like as soon as you
brought it
it got ruined
but but i didn't understand that the you
want to have like a lot of options i
guess just to even get the one and yes
because some will i mean after i got my
eggs uh emily was with me in redondo
remember weren't didn't a couple of them
have down syndrome
like they had to get rid of a couple
uh because they grow so many i mean i
got like 18. you mean they tested that
they test them a couple of them are just
a wash because they're just wonky or
whatever uh some of them will have like
an extra chromosome or something so your
eggs are just in a freezer and redondo
yes they are
they have a beach front view okay how
dare you accuse me of being a shitty
parent
it is 200 a month they are doing great
i'm actually looking for an egg for for
a relative so maybe we can let me know i
don't tell them it's me they'll be like
uh we're good the girl that all she does
is talk about like her inherited
ancestral trauma and addiction issues
like hard pass um but uh but yeah so i
have eggs but the if you've got someone
that you know you want to procreate with
they say that the chances are higher if
you freeze embryos yeah the best but i
didn't know them well yeah and by the
way i
wouldn't do that yet so i would use my i
would do what you did i remember being
at a party at like i think it was like
at the soho house having to do my last
shot in my butt yeah and like i was i
remember i was out on the dance floor
like dancing and i was like oh fuck i
had my my beeper went on my my time my
um
like an alarm alarm went off it starts
beeping and i'm like fuck i have to like
shoot my ass so i like go into the it's
kind of glamorous i know i just remember
like
going into the bathroom at the soho
house and like it has all the vaginas on
the wallpaper
oh that's sweet and just like you know
doing the final one and then just like
throwing you know i just didn't care you
know and i'm glad that it ended up
you know
giving me this
this child and then so you did in vitro
at 40 at 42 or at 41 and then got
pregnant at 42. i don't remember i mean
i just remember it was like harrowing
and it just felt endless and i was
really like at the last you know i i had
this letter written to moshe that was
like you know i don't care if it's not
my eggs i'm at peace with it we can get
donor eggs you know it's as much as i
you know love my nana who worked it made
the salads at the italian restaurant in
rockford like i'm okay if like we go to
a different family line
you know like we can find someone
you know like again if i was janet
jackson
although maybe not well you know and now
that you say it if there's a way to like
separate ancestral mental illness with
just looks and talent
like yeah i don't know if that techno i
know that you can like change your
baby's eye color but like can you change
like the father's side abuse
yeah so i i do think that um
i don't remember what you asked but do
you think that half of it because a lot
of what i hear is that when girlfriends
of mine are trying to get pregnant they
can't get pregnant they can't get
pregnant and then they oh i was at peace
with it yes and then they give up
and the night that they like have a
couple whiskies and just like have
sloppy sex in the garage like that's
when it happens because the stress of
trying which by the way when when people
are like yeah we're trying we're trying
really hard all like you're just being
like we're fucking like at 3 p.m every
day whatever you know what i mean it's
all like that always just is kind of
like a wild thing that became socially
acceptable to just say we're trying and
make everyone just imagine you like
fucking all day but uh
when you're trying and really stressed
out about it you release cortisol and it
kind of shuts your body down it's like
this is not a hospitable which is why
like animals in captivity have a really
hard time procreating because it's like
they're in a lot of stress so it's like
is part of the reason you think you did
get pregnant as part of like oh it's
fine either way
uh no i just kept pumping my body full
of
drugs i know what i always hear
the second someone is like all right
whatever i guess we'll just adopt like i
know friends that
got surrogates where like i can't have
kids started just having sex and have
two kids born in the same year one via
surrogate and they got pregnant because
it's amazing because they were like not
thinking about it not trying which is
kind of fascinating
yeah i mean i'm sure it's different for
everybody but i i do think that if it's
your goal to have a kid and you're like
you know feeling like it's time you just
have to kind of put all your energy into
it did you like being pregnant
i trust me i know what the answer is
this is why i love you because you're
not like being pregnant was amazing no i
hated it i like i didn't i didn't know i
saw you at the comedy store and i was so
uncomfortable i just wanted to like i
scheduled my c-section it was like
scheduled for 10 11 a.m at like 9 50. i
went into the room at like 1007 my baby
was born i had put on eyeliner and like
i had like this amazing picture
like moshe took a picture of me like
when they plopped the baby on my chest
and like it was done
did you did moshe see it come out oh and
because let me just tell you this
i should show you i
i plan the c-section so the scar is like
literally that big now i love it whereas
like a lot of times it's an emergency
c-section that's what my mom had that's
what all my friends have so that can
just be like this because they're like
we can't because everyone's like i want
to have it naturally
so
you know but my
my gynecologist was really cool he was a
gay guy and i was like can i please just
schedule my c-section and he's like well
you're really not supposed to do that
why not
why not why not
i mean i guess you're well it wasn't
dilating though you know and i already
knew like i was so small you know and my
my mom had three
why if is it like some kind of like
conspiracy i know naomi wolf who people
are really mad at now wrote a whole book
about uh what was it called um can you
uh i guess i could look it up but in
brazil i think it's illegal and it's or
it's well but also there's so much money
to be made from like surgeries later
repairing your vision you know like i
have friends i have a friend you
probably know her uh who tore it 18
inches total and had to get the vaginal
tightening and had a catheter for the
first three months of having her child
while breastfeeding and couldn't pee
like it was a nightmare like i don't
understand why there's so much um
uh the glorification of getting torn in
half if you don't have to
well i don't really get it but i do
think it's like women who maybe are a
little more feminine than we are
want to have that experience
of like the earth mother or something i
mean i don't know i i don't relate to it
but maybe they think that it's like
coming through them you know coming
through them it's you're making a tiny
vagina in the stomach like what's the
difference i don't know i don't
understand i'm never having another one
i dated i love and you have the best um
uh quote ever about this what one one
child is a
choice and moshe keeps saying that's my
quote i'm like that is a famous quote
you keep talking quoting me and i'm like
that is not my it's basically yours
basically i just heard somewhere i don't
remember where that one child is an
accessory two is a lifestyle
and i was like oh that's exactly i want
i don't want the lights
perfect i heard you guys you were
talking the other day about having more
than one kid is it ethical to have four
or five kids all that kind of stuff
which is a really fascinating argument
oh cause moshe was saying he didn't
think it was ethical well i my smartest
friends or my most uh law degree
phd friends are not having children
because they're like it's unethical to
bring a child into the world based on
what we know the future is going to look
like
well this is interesting because i'm
writing a book right now and it's called
the world deserves my children and it's
about
this
it's not out yet but i do think that you
know i've kind of grappled with this a
lot and
i don't know i'm probably being very
naive but i just feel like you need an
army for the apocalypse and
and i also think we need like
little greta's you know
all i mean who's gonna save us if not
this generation
not that but then it's i'm sure it's not
ethical to be trying to have because you
know like if my mom told me i should be
an environmental scientist i'd be like
fuck you you know so
it's not that but i do send my kid to
like a nature school and i want her to
fall in love with the world and nature
and yeah and you know obviously like
it'd be amazing if she was an
environmentalist and
you know even though i i can't compost
maybe she will um no you can't but i
mean i do grapple with this and i'm sure
someone could write in and say why it's
the i'm wrong but i i do feel like it's
worth a shot here's the thing stupid
people are procreating constantly so i
don't think that smart people should be
restrained themselves and don't we need
like like when legislation starts
getting passed about the environment and
global warming don't we need like people
to be voting in the right
way i don't know i mean if we only let
uh you know what did they just say in
florida if you get vaccinated you can't
come to school for 30 days have you seen
this they're saying because
because people don't understand science
and they're like
we don't we think it's bad to get
vaccinated
you might spread something to us i mean
it doesn't make anybody have the virus
technically
no oh i don't know i mean it doesn't
make any sense i'm just saying like you
can't just let
you know those people have kids like
don't we want like to to have or
i mean until the four or five people
that are in control of all media
decide to
be ethical in terms of like allowing
misinformation and stuff it's like
because we're about to have a country
run by older people basically like
everyone is about to be older and
they're the most vulnerable to
misinformation because they're not as
tech savvy i i started listing this
podcast called you're wrong about and
they debunk things about the oj trial
and
um tanya harding and anna nicole smith
like the things that we kind of were
like oh we thought that was the story
they're like no annika and nicole smith
was really cool and she didn't want that
guy for her his money
if you just john
okay but if you just listen to me can
you please post that picture of them
but here's what i'm saying
she's like propping him up and he's like
by the way gold diggers she's like we're
in love and she's like dressed as a
clown men that are gold digged
they are consenting and want it so if
you're a billionaire
right and you're you make great deals
for a living that's how you became a
billionaire and then all of a sudden
this this dumb woman is going to come
along and convince you to do a bad deal
all of a sudden
i don't buy this like men being preyed
on thing i just don't buy it i don't
really buy that either but that man in
particular
seems very senile
i mean he was in his late 90s still
doing deals though at the time he was
still doing whatever he uh real estate
deals or whatever he was doing i do not
really buy this
uh did i think that men that get gold
digged want to be gold digged why are
you driving aston martin why do you have
these nine houses if you're not trying
to bait rich women he was she he saw her
at a strip club basically invited her
why not
wait so so but you're saying that when
you say that the world's about to be run
by old people you don't mean that age
not that age no because the boomers uh
she was saying that in the next 10 years
i think it's something like 60 percent
of the population is going to be between
55 and 75. well you know what's great
about the pandemic is that it is
definitely we've called out some of the
people
that
think everything on facebook is true no
i'm not saying that
you said that no yes i did here's what
i'm saying about about the pandemic is i
feel like we all just like went into
this like hibernation for a year and a
half and now even the old people like
we're all just idiots like everyone's on
tick tock my dad my 75 year old father
came to visit he couldn't i was like can
you help me with the k on his phone the
whole time like like ding ding ding ding
he's playing like games i don't know
what the hell he's doing i'm like can
you at least like fast forward the
youtube videos for my child's like
screen time like they were very
unhelpful and i'm just i just think and
then my my friends were my age i went
over to their house recently and it's
just like oh do you want to try these
new sprinkles i learned the recipe on
tick tock oh your skin looks good thank
you i it's 16 step process of skin
cleaning i learned on tik tok oh do you
like this um do you like what i did in
my kitchen it's uh the mason jars are in
descending order i learned it on tick
tock and like everyone's on tick tock
like i'm not doing that i just
everyone's just dumb now benton and i
just had a really big fight about this i
bet you're on tick tock i am on tick
tock i don't run it it's just clips from
the podcast what you just did will be
uploaded to tick-tock i i just can't i'm
not gonna do it like anything i think
that there's things that are super
helpful on there like the recipes and
the scenes i learned
i do not go on tick-tock emily sends
tock clips that are so crazy we end up
never airing them
because we're not clear the strat tick
tock strategy
i am clear of the tick tock strategy i
am cool matt just
just madness like i think now tick-tock
has started to be more of like an
instructional type thing but i was i was
fighting with benton about it because i
was like i do not believe it's uh
effective use of my time currently i
don't think that people are making big
comedy careers out of it i don't think
people do you feel good after you're on
tick tock i don't go on it because is it
edifying it i don't like watching lazy
cheerleading so number one every time i
go on there it feels like girls that are
very young in swimsuits dancing and i
feel like i'm gonna lose my kid in a
custody battle in ten years if that's on
my search no the worst is like people
were in their mid 50s or like famous
celebrities who are like now trying to
do like dancing videos it's making me
uncomfortable when i see like a
celebrity with their hair and then they
bend it and it's like in their facial
mask and like because i know how long it
takes to make something that's 10
seconds on tick tock takes like four
hours ew really it takes so long to get
something where someone is like has no
makeup on and then they hit their head
on the camera and then they come back
and they have makeup on that takes like
four hours remember we tried to shoot
one of those ones with ben because you
have to then be in two hours of hair and
makeup and then you have to hit it in
the same spot it's like all i it's like
why i don't like guys that are really in
shape even if your body looks good all i
can do is picture you in the gym for
three hours and i know i feel the same
way i can't separate the product from
how long and how desperate totally
that's like less time you've been
reading books correct because it's like
a two hours it's leg day if this took 10
seconds i'm like okay that's cool i get
it but if i'm like i know how much
production time this took and i now feel
sad for you by the way nothing against
spending your time on tick tock it's
just ice is not for me and then i just
feel like what my dad everyone i know
from like a a
eight-year-old to a 75 year old is
addicted to their phone here's what i'll
say tick tock for the most part is what
we when we were teenagers we did that in
the mirror it was like you're dancing
with your hairbrush and you're like
making up a like a dance to a certain
salt pepper song like that was not to be
recorded you know that was just like us
being silly that was not to be
documented for no public consumption
okay so to me it's charity the dancing
in front of like a laundry basket on
your bed like in a
bra and like little shorts like i just i
feel like i don't know how old anyone is
and it feels very sexual to me maybe
that's just my algorithm whitney i
looked at your instagram the other day
and you had a picture of your fucking
vagina your bald vagin first of all
you take the hair off the top of your
vagina i did that once i i pulled my toe
it hurts so bad
it hurts so bad she took it off the top
and i like my whole body shot i couldn't
walk for a week oh this one yeah yeah
yeah i got i got a lot of shit i got a
lot of shit for this wait it is just
your vagina on a balcony okay
where were the uh the rest of my body is
on it as well oh also with with with
tick-tock and instagram too like
i'm just feeling like
like i just don't i don't want to have
to like post
everything
totally and i think that
my deal with this is as someone that i
know gets made i got a job i'm on a
private plane look how good my makeup
looks today sure i know that
you
get all of your emotional needs met
internally into your relationship and i
think that's cool is someone that is not
satisfied by romantic relationships
that's very rude to your boyfriend i
he knows it and i want to be very clear
the only thing that makes me feel good
is money and i'm totally fine saying
that and what you put into social media
i think you end up getting out other
ways and like if you really want to
i mean anyone that's like like touring
like it just helps unfortunately but for
me i think people in their brain think
i'm just constantly documenting all the
time like i'll shoot a bunch of stuff
i'll like bank it i'll post it later
like it's it's not that much skin off my
back but i think a lot of people think
that i probably over share or do social
media too much but it has been worth it
to me work work-wise
and i kind of like the idea that like we
don't have to rely on other people for
promotion we don't have to go do like
shecky and the moose like local like
you know oh my god morning radio wait do
you think that's over now that's like
pandemic monkey and porky on the 10.
kiki and the giraffe it's always always
and it's always like always like oh yeah
we met in high school and there's always
like a girl who they all objectify and
then it's like it's fajita wednesdays
and it's like 8 a.m and they're like
making videos eating bugs and you're
like i'm it's 4 00 a.m you know like i
can't do the morning radio i would say
five morning radio djs have called me a
spinner what's that mean it's like you
don't know because you're tall it's like
they're it's like their idea of like
they're like it's a short woman you can
put her on your dick and then spin her
around you never heard of this
hey asshole you have a pot belly so how
could you wouldn't be able to spin me
around
it's just like they don't have any old
beasts what's your name are you the worm
are you porky porky in the worm
i've always liked i think that's a real
one honestly it might be i'm like who's
the worm again who's the mad cow
did anyone have a name oh wait mad cow i
remember that guy
back house huge i remember once i i had
an interview i was like it was um it was
for like the first it was my first radio
interview and i was playing someone on
it was on joe schmoe i think my name was
rita the drunk and that was my name and
they had me do this like radio tour and
it was with man cow is that his name a
man
or a man man okay chicago based huge
yeah so i get on the phone with him i'm
like it's natasha lejo he's like i'm on
the phone with read of the drunk and i
was like no my name's natasha he's like
you're rita the drunk so rita and he
just like kind of like yes and it was
like he steamrolled me and i was just
like really kind of embarrassed and i
was horrified
probably i mean sorry i'm making your
name better
could any woman be like cow like natasha
the cow like it's why it's always so
sausage in the it's always it's always
an animal i know
um and uh yeah the girls names are
always just like such a bummer um like
spooky or like
their names are yeah
and they just do like the traffic report
and just kind of get like
sex sex you know slurs thrown at them um
hold on i can actually because i did do
for this tour i just did a little bit of
radio no joke oh no you should check to
make sure i just basically did no man
count i'm
do not cut this man cal i absolutely
will criticize this show it's fucking
crazy uh i went it's very hard here's
what i will say it was a pivotal moment
in my life because i realized that as
hard as it is to be a touring comedian
at the time i was going in
on a wednesday doing a wednesday night
show you would get up and do radio at
5am the next morning do uh show thursday
get up do 5am radio the next morning and
then two shows friday two shows saturday
one show sunday like that's when we're
doing just like a week at a club and so
uh getting on mad cow was like a huge
deal man cow
mad cow is a disease now that he's older
i feel like all radio djs are mad right
now because of podcasts oh totally what
do you think so i feel like matt they're
all mad um so he is mad he's mad don't
you think so
okay i go in this was probably when i
was like 26 or something i go in at five
in the morning you're exhausted you did
a show before like some random like and
why do you have to go in it's like so
annoying some hungover like waitress
drives you there
you've got to like make make a
conversation like five in the morning
hanging from the rear view mirror
it's like you're driving around and
there's like four stops and then like
you you get to like have a little hour
long break but then the next radio is at
like 11 a.m so you never get to like
have like a a nap before your next show
40 minutes apart yeah for some reason
yeah there's one at night at like 6 a.m
6 15 and 6 40 and then like 11.
there's always like an awesome amount of
time and um
so i go in
and i realize the a band came in that i
think was
not samford and sons who's the the one
carrie mulligan is married to the guy
i'm fernie mumford and son
sorry i music is not where i shine
everyone knows this i don't but 70s
sitcoms i'll tell you what i wait that i
can do
so um because that's the era i was meant
to make television and so um uh i go in
and i'm like oh it's a nightmare like
why did i choose to do this like this is
like awful and then this mumford and
sons comes in
and it's four guys or it felt like seven
it was just like there's too many people
in that band and they all have
instruments and i was like
the only thing worse than doing this is
having to carry
like a like a bass like a cello
at 5 00 a.m and be with like four other
people like you know what i mean i was
like this could be worse you could have
to play like
5 a.m can you at least i get to be like
this is a nightmare i made my life
i was like that is worse thank god we're
not in a band yeah but you know what's
good about them they can kind of like
wear sunglasses because like i was kind
of trying to do that like i'm just going
to wear sunglasses to morning radio
because they always want to like take
your picture and video it but i don't
want to ever put on makeup and i don't
and they always like talk about your
appearance these guys they're always
like what's it like
yeah or i don't know too but i also felt
like i like pressure to not just show up
in the robe or you know sure can i ask
you something why are have for so long
have we been accused of lying about our
ages what do you think that is
i haven't been accused
i just looked into this i'm like hey so
why does everyone hate us you're like uh
speak for yourself bitch well no i guess
because so many people conflated us for
like a minute at least like i would get
like dms like of have natasha and
whitney ever been in the same room like
i would get like stuff like that oh and
chelsea lately people always would tell
me that they were a fan and then after
like a few sentences i'm like oh they
think i'm whitney
but i would just let that i would get
that a lot too people like love you the
franco roast i'd like thank you so much
i would absolutely just go with that
it's like thank you so much um people
tell you that you're lying about your
age in the when i started
i mean who cares
i just it's just interesting to me it's
just like i would go on radio shows
because i remember people like oh
because you're okay so how old are you
they'd like google it show me your
license like it was a lot of like that
and it was like
i'm tired and poor
yeah i look and also why would i lie
about my age i'd never get away with it
if i you know what i'm saying i almost
want to lie older so the people started
to believe me but it there was just like
a time where i felt like
i don't know i just felt like female
comics in general just get accused of
lying about their age a lot it's like
yeah well i'm i've been dehydrated for
15 years and i go to sleep at four in
the morning and i have to wake up for
like you're just making me think about
like how harry harrowing our schedules
were for so long i hated that um getting
up and doing the radio and it is very
brutal it's definitely the worst part
because in the beginning when you're not
known you can't just go on and be
yourself you have to like do bits
they'll be like they would say send a
setup and you'd go ask me about you know
snowboarding and they'd be like and then
you'd have to like do a bit and a lot of
comedians like like the first comedian
you had to
carry his merch uh
uh in a bag that i had to check this was
the most bone chilling thing i've ever
seen he was divorced and before he went
on stage he would put on a wedding ring
because all of his bits were about being
married and i just remember looking like
that and looking at that and being like
don't
do that like you can't i like i can't
you talked about this on i think it was
rupaul's uh podcast uh about how
once you've outgrown a bit or once
you're a different person you can't do
material i know moshe's always like just
do some old stuff i'm like i can't
person anything i don't i i can't do it
yeah i can't like talk about like
wanting to do coke i have a child like
right i'm just planning on like
what
future lawyers have access to in a
custody battle like i think about that
all the time now i'm like i just can't
make that joke anymore but um but yeah i
just remember going like i hope i i
never want to
lie on stage does that make sense like i
never want to like have to like do an
act or like a character like if i'm not
in that place
and then uh yeah so i had to bring his
luggage because he had books and i'd
have to like do the credit card machines
and like all that stuff and like hold up
his merch he would like talk over the
loudspeaker and i would like hold up
shirts and then um yeah so it was eighty
dollars to check the bag and i had to
pay for the bag check fee because it was
so heavy it was like 100 pounds like a
giant check on that you had to check
that to go on the road with him correct
yes and
then he would ask me to pick up his kids
from school and i was like oh i guess
it's like in thousand oaks
like i didn't know and then i talked to
like danny eagle or something i was like
i was like yeah it's just it's a lot of
work you know
picking up the kid and she's like you're
picking up his kid i was like yeah he
keeps asking like for no money like it
was just wild how like
dumb imagine doing that to somebody i
can't
well i think that um your work ethic is
inspiring whitney and i think that you
remind us all how how much we should be
working no you i feel like we have i
feel like
every time we see each other
there's a little bit of a like
like i
really admire how balanced your life at
least like seems it seems like when
you're with your family you're really
able to be with your family but then
when you're on your you're like 100 when
you're on your podcast you're 100 when
you're on stage whereas i think i'm
maybe a little more manic and a little
more uh
addict-y about work and i think i also
but you have way more money
which makes you happy but i buy way less
gold
if you were to sell all your gold i feel
like we might have the same amount of
money it's not that much i mean here's
i've been saving up for my collection
and i just never take it off so i just
wanted to be able to like
be able to just
wear whatever yeah and just be able to
have but i mean you know what else
rachel does the the goldsmith she'll do
like half silver so it's cheaper so the
silver will be here
and then sometimes you know she knows
when gold is cheap so i can like buy it
you know gold always goes up and down so
you kind of have to buy it during the
lean times
if you know
like i feel like
my new definition of success is knowing
like where like what the price of gold
is
you know like if you're like gold now is
not the time to buy gold like this is a
20-year collection whitney okay i'd find
that like is there an app like i
wouldn't even know where to start
well i i wouldn't either she she tells
me i also probably have more money than
you because i live in a part of town
that is not a scam
well don't tell people where you live
i'm just telling you oh that ship has
sailed um but uh i i feel like for me
i've taken a hit maybe socially or maybe
like cool factor wise because
i went i moved to studio city first
which was like when i moved there 10
years ago was the first house i ever
bought everyone was like eight one eight
ew like gross like why are you living in
the valley i don't think that's a thing
anymore i don't think so anymore now
that our friends are like having kids
and want to get into certain like school
districts but that
went up i made so much money on buying
in a place that was not desirable at the
time and then that paid for the whole
day and then i'm now in a place where a
lot of people are like where so i feel
like
the key to being able to like
save money is living in a place where
people are like why do you live there
because i probably end up like i looked
at places in your area and i was just
like this is
a while it's just a wild amount it's
like really expensive
um well please don't tell people where i
live i won't i didn't i didn't bel-air
um
okay i have so many questions for you
yes there is a picture of me on uh uh
instagram that almost made my lover
leave me
of me naked on a balcony can we show
this yeah because you know i also don't
pay for hotels i only do like paid
partnership things like exchanges so how
do you do that you just say hey do you
have an influencer this is your
influence yes
yes thank you w at w berg hotel
i heard that's a good hotel but it's a
wonderful hotel great view yes
i mean i wasn't talking about your pussy
i was talking about the actual
view of new york behind you um so i
lasered that all of that when i was 25.
so it's just gone i regret it every day
you have no vagina hair i'm freezing
none
sometimes little smithers hairs grow
randomly like a like scraggler you were
just like take it all off i it was a
time where that was the
you know i was dating pedophiles no i i
think it just was like shaving it i
would get like ingrowns and then i would
panic and think it was like herpes then
i'd go to the dyno which was like 400
and i couldn't afford it so i just was
like how many sessions to get at that
ball i guess it was like six maybe wow
did you get your legs done too legs too
but that didn't really like my knees
that didn't stay and that'll get random
like a really long one just get like
random long ones on your vagina and then
your knees are really hairy
sounds worth it
back to ads
that's your casual break into ads yeah
you're just going back to ads
yeah i mean isn't this the first stop in
ads
yeah but we're going back to them are we
i mean like
back to
oh welcome to ads everyone oh okay fine
welcome to ads oh no i didn't want you
to redo it i was just okay you better
help
better help um we do need better help
because
whitney's not here so we have no literal
help yeah um so we're doing ads alone
again the patients are running the
asylum
better help listen we were on the road
recently
and um we met
a therapist in in the wild
who recommends not only good for you to
their clients but also better help and
if you don't we talk about it a lot we
rambled on about better health for a
couple years at this point and if you
don't believe us please believe this
licensed professionalist professional
please please please tell me you got
video
yeah bro cut video great
so i'm a therapist do you recommend good
for you to clients fantastic like so
many episodes i actually i think last
two weeks ago i sent like six episodes
to one client
how do you feel about better hill
i looked into doing it actually i still
haven't it's oh wow you would as a
therapist use
[Music]
amazing is what she was going to end
that with yeah but i was done um
literally that is a therapist that said
he would not only use better help but he
looked into actually doing better help
that's it and as we know because we say
it all the time they're hiring in all 50
states he has co-workers that work for
better health
i cannot think of a better better health
a better better health amazing we asked
you guys to do our ads and now you are
so thank you very much yes better help
will assess your needs and match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist it's not men it's not a crisis
line it's not self-help it is a
professional counseling done securely
online
it really is better help is committed to
facilitating great therapeutic matches
so they make it easy and free to change
counselors if needed because finding the
correct counselor is the most important
part you got yeah and your podcast
were going to say something else yeah i
was just going to say it's good to have
a therapist who's in therapy you know
what i mean and then you have a
grandfather therapist so that's cool you
know what i mean yeah i like about
uh uh what are those russian nesting
russian nesting dollar therapist yeah
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
and good for your listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
whitney speaking of whitney um
i
was scrounging around her personal
belongings
thinking
that maybe we could
make a profit
off selling some of it on ebay wait a
minute to pay off our students i've been
doing this no way i've also been i have
a video of me in the airport i've also
been i've been stealing her starbucks
cup that she licked all over and i've
been selling them
on depop for a pretty little penny oh my
god here we go let me see
you really shouldn't film yourself
stealing things but i was hot i was
caught i'm glad we have it for this ad
did you drink one of this
yeah okay i'm gonna keep it why i'm
gonna sell it to pay off my student
loans no
no okay can i have your car kind of your
bra
i'm not wearing a bra
okay can we get some and we'll just
oh can you sign a couple bras i heard
that they sell really good online is
this real especially if you sweat on
them is this where my used underwear has
been going
no comment
ernest
enter earnest
oh yeah give my coffee back yeah she did
suggest that instead of selling items
like her you know hair brush full of
hair and this tissue she used which will
be on ebay um then i could just go to
earnest.com and refinance my student
loans that would be a much uh smarter
and less creepy thing to do in the
airport if you saw that i looked uh
i didn't look great if you want to pay
off your student loans faster listen up
ernest was voted best student loan
refami
refinancing overall by nerd wallet
nerd wallet
with earnest it only takes two minutes
to see what your new rate could be and
there's no credit impact and right now
ernest is offering our listeners a
hundred dollar cash bonus refinance your
student debt at earnest.com whitney not
available in all states
once again you'll get a hundred dollar
cash bonus when you visit earnest.com
whitney to refinance your student loans
stop selling your friends tissue tissues
visit earnest.com whitney for more
details not available in all states
terms and conditions apply earn a
student loan refinancing made by earnest
operations llc nmls number one 204 917
california financing law license number
605-4788-535 mission street san
francisco california
94105 visit earnest.com licenses for a
full list of licenses this is licenses
earnest.com
fix your life
fix your life i'm trying now back to
natasha i have like
very aggressive nipple hairs i don't
know what part of my ancestry
has this but i did zap a couple nipple
hairs i did in between my eyebrows
um
that's just so much work aren't you just
always driving to appointments i did it
at a time when i didn't have a ton going
on i feel i did it like 25 26. smart um
but here's what i will say i went to my
gyno
a couple years ago and i always ask her
like what's the like word on the street
like what are the hottest trends like is
the job growing it out all kinds of
things like are g-spot fillers is that
real because you hear that you can get
your g-spot injected with fillers so
that you have an orgasm more easily yeah
you need to get on reddit um
and then like like vaginal rejuvenation
and and porn
um there's a lot of i was like talking
about it in a special or something how
in porn um a lot of people don't talk
about how unrealistic it is because
there's a lot of labiaplasties where
they sort of cut off the labia and a
friend of mine's daughter at 16 got with
a guy for the first time
obviously
16 year old boys now have seen way more
they've seen naked women before they
ever see in
virtually before they ever see one in
person right so they've only seen tons
and tons of porn stars and then they see
a real woman
she got naked and he was like what is
that like he like freaked out every
girl's
worst nightmare because number one she
had pubes and number two she had her
labia was longer than her pussy lips and
in porn that's not normal
well like
at 16 i mean i'm not a porn star but i
don't think my labia hangs lower than
the lips
is that what you're saying
am i wrong i think
wait okay
so this is your pussy yeah
yeah whitney okay hold on oh i know why
because you have no hair or anything so
yours you can see everything really yeah
but if you they
okay but okay should we just show them
hold on
this is now i really need to let's just
do it this is i need a zoom call someone
real quick okay so this is your pussy
okay so that's that surprisingly does
kind of look like a clit
i'm trying i'm trying to fit like a long
clip like a naked woman uh bottle opener
that i'm trying so if that's your pussy
lips that your labia can like come out
to there
i didn't dude emily agrees with me
whitney does no one's labia but i think
it sounds cute
drugstick
am i at her mouth tonight what's
happening i know i today i look like
karen top transitioned but i know your
hair looks cute that color
um
look vaginas are like snowflakes they're
all different
uh
if your pussy was bald are you telling
me that i've never had a ball i told you
i did it once
and
it hurts so bad i i because you waxed or
i wax oh yeah see that's that's sick i
think waxing yeah i mean i never did it
again waxing is barbaric no i was
wearing one of those like
leg braces it hurts it i pulled my toe
it's
that soup camel toe and so
uh anyway if yours hangs down that's
okay but it doesn't hang the way you're
saying it is making it sound like a
turkey gizzard or like a turkey now the
way you're saying it is making it sound
like that gently
peeks out it sounds like it's just a
cute little thing yes it is it sounds
really cute it's like a raindrop it is a
it is a it's like it's it's now if we
took that picture that you took at the
hotel your influencer picture and zoomed
it do you think we could maybe see
are you trying to tell me wait hold on
that does look really cute okay are you
trying to tell me whitney you're not
going to show yourself
right now you have a couple pubes look
okay it's not always out i feel like i
need to show you my c-section scar now
did your um
abs tear apart no idea oh i had some no
i didn't have abdominal separation
because abdominal separation is is when
you have give birth naturally it happens
then yeah because a friend of mine
worked with this trainer meghan trainor
it's on her instagram and stuff who
who's a pregnancy
trainer that does these things so that
your abs don't split apart yeah that had
a beyonce yeah and i think they rebuild
they can do it
attach them so hopefully beyonce watches
this and the next time she has a baby
she does her little plan c-section yeah
and listens to us
um we do have the same birthday whatever
um but you've been inspiring me a lot
because i think that for the most part i
like
i don't know i feel like i've kind of
been like oh i guess i'm gonna have to
adopt or i guess i'm gonna just like buy
a kid or whatever so how have i inspired
you
you're gonna use some of your eggs
number one i don't think i knew that you
carried your child at 42.
oh yeah i don't know i i feel like i
just have always i just feel like you're
30 and you're still i just feel like
we're still 30 and it's just like a lot
to process that we're not 30 anymore
well i will say that my doc my
gynecologist told me he said your uterus
is a 10 out of 10. oh so your uterus has
like a rate like they can kind of rate
your uterus your uterus got cat called
by your
but like is your uterus completely
healthy i mean someone who has who's 30
might have like a uterus that's like a
four and it might i mean i don't think
it's a rating
i don't know why the doctor said that i
don't i think he was just like you it's
sturdy you can you can carry the child
but you know it doesn't necessarily what
what what
that led to this analysis
i i honestly think he was kind of coming
on to me i'm not going to lie
you've been molested because natasha's
coming forward this is an andrew yang's
wife situation fully
i don't know what happened there i'm not
laughing at that
i just want you to know i'm not up on
that it is a it is a deep cut and i'm
it's definitely going to bring more
attention to the cause people will be
cutting that people will be not people
we are not a deep cut we're cutting out
i am drawing attention to a cause i just
did that and you're not going to take my
activism away from me well i will say
that like i am very happy that me too
happened because i do think that like
even like little things that have
happened to me like i remember this
gynecologist i was trying to have this
baby and i was like also talking to this
other gynecologist because it wasn't
working out with this one and fertility
expert and he found out and i remember
he had his fingers inside me
and he was like you're gonna have to
pick a doctor but i remember like it was
like really aggressive and his fingers
were in me and i'm just like
a woman would not do this you know and
i'm not saying it was traumatic but it
definitely like i was just that's the
most vulnerable you can be and you know
like in terms of like a doctor's
appointment you know and i just feel
i just feel like people wouldn't do that
now and then it's like i think i think
for that right at least give me some
half off yeah like make some part of
this experience pleasurable but but i
love the idea of men being like paranoid
this extra layer now of paranoia like
what can i get away with what can i how
can i treat people you know especially
when i'm when i get to like be touching
or not get to but like when my job is to
like have my fingers inside them i am
like full disclosure this is a joke i've
been doing but it's about this and um
how when we were kids we
we got naked at every doctor i mean when
i was a kid you were naked at every
doctor like now there's a chaperone at
the gynecologist there's like a nurse
making sure everything's okay and you
know all that kind of stuff and when we
were kids we got naked at every doctor
and i feel like what happened is women
started becoming doctors and they
they looked at the protocols and like
they don't need to be naked at the ear
nose and throat doctor like you psychos
so right
what we used to do with doctors is so
wild when you think about it and so
unnecessary and creepy and insane in the
breast exams and the um
but also just the bedside manner of
and this is part of the reason when i
went to freeze my eggs this happened and
i know this is going to sound like i'm
some delicate flower and i can really
handle a lot because i'm able to
disassociate
having had abuse in my childhood like i
really can just like pretend it's not
happening like i can block really
horrific stuff out and i know that's not
great like how i blocked out our open
mic that we did in like the late 90s
my sexual assault you block out our
hangs the way i block out my sexual
assaults
i'm not going to laugh at that no please
come on it's fine that is when you're
healed when you can laugh about it well
i'm sorry i'm a big fan of punching down
um and so oh but i think that's a really
great point that once women become
doctors and women start like yeah no you
can keep your clothes on for this like
i'll go to doctors even i'll just start
and they're like no no you you can wear
a robe we've got a robe for you not like
a tiny post-it note paper bib like
here's a robe
and
if you need to take your shirt off we'll
let you know and now remember it used to
be a gown that opened in the front now
it's like a smock that is closed in the
front i mean just little things where
you're just like oh this used to only be
run by men
and
it's just it's wild to think about the
more women everything the better they
think about when there was how many
ma how many female producers were there
in the 1930s i mean zero no and like
women went west for herself yeah you
would have to like apologize to a
producer if he tried to rape you you
know it's just like it was awful i was
just reading in gloria vanderbilt's book
she was saying that
um when she was little she remembers
this is probably in the 30s the doctor
her nanny took her to the doctor and the
doctor wanted naked pictures of her as
like a toddler and then she remembers
the doctor just putting him in a in a in
a
drawer in his office with like his other
naked pictures
and it's just like you're right like men
were just like oh yeah this is what we
do
yeah and
i'm a dog
invincible yeah of course of course um
but name of your next special um
and but to me honestly like the physical
stuff like i've gotten so numb around
physical stuff at this point but um i've
just gotten very desensitized to it and
i can completely like go out of body but
to me
the most traumatic thing that i heard
when i was freezing my eggs was i had um
this amazing fertility doctor who's like
very gentle there's a woman and this
other guy and then there was an older
man that one time when i went in and got
an exam just to see if the eggs were
growing whatever like the sonogram the
routine every couple days sonogram to
make sure the sizes are equal or
whatever he said you know well since
this is this would be a geriatric
pregnancy
and because all pregnancies over 34 are
considered geriatric that is a man who
invented that and it was just like it
was just the kind of thing where i was
like i'm not a big like word person
secretary assistant whatever like i'm
like whatever i'm happy to use any words
whatever but
i it like it really upset me because it
was just like oh this is just like a
weirdly archaic word the irony is he was
geriatric the fact that he was using
that but it just felt like a really
unnecessary loaded word that the term is
100 invented by a man and i think you
just have to like i like it'll it'll
it'll it'll swap out totally it like
broke my spirit it it like it it
discouraged me and made me want to give
up and maybe that's just me and and but
it just felt like 34. imagine like a man
who's 45 is like at the pinnacle of his
career and he's like you know it's it's
it's just not equal
it was just shitty and maybe that was
like an appropriate term 30 years ago or
something and now it's like because so
like whenever anyone's like
call me this you know like what it's
always like if that word is upsetting to
you i'll change it like i i i if if if
calling you this or mrs or comedienne or
comic versus comedian like anything
anyone wants to change up like i because
i remember that i had such a
i mean maybe it was irrational like like
histrionic response to it i was like
sobbing i was also on hormones and all
kinds of stuff so maybe i was like more
sensitive but i remember that just being
so unnecessary and i said i will he's
like i'm on my third family i know yeah
but it was like because i was 33 at the
time so he's like because any pregnancy
you have is going to be geriatric
basically if you have it now and i was
like i'm not planning on getting
pregnant like 10 years like so i'm gonna
be
geriatric like it just was like a to me
a wildly archaic word i was like he's
got his fingers inside me he doesn't
care but like that word felt so
dismissive and
unnecessarily rough
that because to me it's kind of more
that kind of stuff that gets me
i'm sorry that that happened but you
know you're you still seem very young no
thank you very much but it was just like
one of those things i was like oh this
is like an institutionalized aegis
sexist thing that needs to change and
i'm i'm like the first person to go like
it's ageless to assume that that guy's
gonna know the more gentle term he's you
know like and i hate to just be like i
don't want to engage with that person
anymore but i was just like if you can't
ascertain that that's
like hurtful or the the if you if you
don't know the weight of that word
you're just you can't read a room and i
felt very dis it was like a very
dismissive
nasty like just so you know
well that's why i always try to find
female doctors yeah you know and i i try
to have just more women around me at all
times
and it's kind of like um and moshe gets
very mad at me and he's like i'm sick of
everything being you know you you split
everything i'm just it's a phase i'm
going through i just want more women
around me like i mean think about it
like you're boarding a plane like do you
want to sit by a woman or a man
yeah last time i sat by a man this guy
was like
chewing sunflower seeds and spitting
them out in an old diet coke bottle and
then i was telling people and they're
like oh that's just a baseball player
i'm like i don't fucking care like
that's fucking disgusting and like a
woman would never do that i saw a guy
snort half of his nose into a plant the
other day like he was walking down the
street and he just had to like blow his
nose so he like like held it and snorted
it it's like women don't do stuff like
that no of course not i just want women
around me right even if they were at
lilith fair surrounded by women and
feeling safe like it's not
it's not it just wouldn't happen also
i would say as people that are travel a
lot a hundred percent of the people on
planes that watch youtube videos sound
on no headphones
are men and i have i mean i have to be
home i am the home monitor bitch on the
plane i'm the person that will just like
excuse me sir like people are sleeping
like oh can you like i am
always that bitch and but now you don't
want to do that because there's so many
fights breaking out i'm fine with that
oh it's my dream i have a very deep um
uh
need to be on world desire to be violent
and if i have like an app like i think
part of the reason like i'm very
effective as a rescue dog rescue or
animal rescue person is because like i
would i am that bitch that like i mean
i'm
i mean i come from like west virginia
like hatfield and mccoy like ancestry
like if i actually have a justified
reason
to
uh go berserk on someone i'm like
thrilled to be there i'm like i got this
stand down like i'm i'm made for this
and i don't get to do it
ever and like this is actually like
justified and i'm doing it for the right
reasons instead of just like for the
adrenaline and
like love of the game
but because you're like a good samaritan
yeah i have a lot of
superpowers that are perceived as
character defects they call them in
program flaws
limitations wait what are your
superpowers some people call it mental
illness
i call it a super power a superpower
that would have served me very well 2
000 years ago i just believe i was born
in the wrong time period i i should have
been alive in like the early 1800s me
too
i would have been you were definitely
you should you i believe yeah should
have just been like a queen
or royal don't you think
i mean i probably was a prostitute you
think that's that's what i just feel
like you're just bragging
like people would pay to have sex with
me no i feel like i was always low class
really well i just have like an
association with like
just like um transcending your class
or i don't know that that's just what
i've always been obsessed with like
because i grew up poor
and i was like oh i don't you know when
i moved to la it was like the gap was so
huge and
you know it's it's just uh
it's it's just it was like an obsession
do you remember what the first really
expensive thing you bought was
i mean what do you call really expensive
i mean actually maybe this ring right
here really is that something like when
you first started really like what was
like the like first or a recent like
just big purchase you made that was like
i mean honestly the biggest thing i did
was pay 21 000 to my student loans
because i started to realize
i was paying so much money and interest
and i was like wait if i just paid this
off
then
and then like i remember i had like this
victoria's secret credit card that was
like 200 dollars i owed on it but i was
paying like 70 a month a month it's
crazy crazy for like four years and then
i was like wait a second i've given them
thousands of dollars all i have to do is
pay this off so i think like paying off
all your bills was like that was one
that was like where i just gave it all
when you're like paying like off
collections yes and getting your getting
your um what's it called your credit
score byron allen fixed my credit he did
yes that's so nice of him so whenever
anyone clowns on me i still anytime
byron allen calls i show up whatever it
is
not only he's a brilliant businessman
and i'm always like what do i invest in
help me like unders where do i buy real
estate he's getting a star on the walk
of fame
i know i'm gonna try to go to the
luncheon thing we met one time uh about
me hosting like one of his you know
things i had no money and he was like so
do you have a car and i was like no i
don't i'm i'm gonna get one soon i'm
borrowing one or whatever and he was
like where do you live and i was like
i'm in this apartment but like i was it
was very clear that i was like not able
to achieve a couple things and he just
said he's like do you have a problem
with your credit i was like yes wait so
how did he fix it i couldn't get it he
just called somebody i didn't get an
apartment i couldn't get credit cards
because i didn't have i had so many
things in collections and the problem is
once things are in collections it's hard
to pay them even if you want to know and
i had been moving so it's like i wasn't
getting certain bills like in order to
have credit you have to use a credit
card a lot so i had such low credit that
i was like okay i'm just gonna use cash
and a debit card but then you're not
building credit so like an idiot for two
years i only used a debit card and so
your credit actually goes down you want
to be
charging stuff to a credit card and
paying it off consistently that's how
you build credit he
wrote on a piece of paper a guy's name
michael farhang
f-a-r-h-n-g called him and he slowly
like figured out where my bills were
like paid those off and he got like
literally fixed my credit in like
amazing it changed my life oh by the way
do you know how i moved to la i was in
new york i lived in harlem it was like a
windowless apartment i was really
depressed and i was like it was like
right before 9 11 and i
chase manhattan bank sent me
a letter and they were like
you've just been given five thousand
dollars in overdraft protection do you
know what that is that just means that
you can just write checks up for up to
five thousand dollars
so i just started writing checks like i
wrote a check to a rental car place in
la i got an apartment and i just like
wrote all these checks and then i was
able to move down
to la but that's another thing like i
you know i didn't understand
how much i would have to pay back the
most fucked up shit is when
you overdraft because i remember putting
my stuff on auto
and so i mean i had seven dollars for
like three years but
i remember when i started having like
200 300 and you're paying off your phone
bill and sometimes it'll charge
automatically if you haven't like put in
a deposit and it would overcharge so if
you like overcharge 20 it'll charge you
like fifty dollars i know it's like i
couldn't afford the twenty dollars like
why like it's such a fucked up system
yeah i know
well i remember like being i live in a
palace now at the bank of america on
sunset
near the rock and roll ralph's in like
fairfax and like crying to this like
armenian woman and being like i'm dating
an armenian guy
can you please because i was at the time
i was like can you please like wave this
and he would like come in and like talk
to her about what did she say because
they would talk about the armenian
genocide and i'd be like that's terrible
the holocaust gets so much more press
than that and then she would wave my fee
wow
not enough people do talk about the
armenian genocide i mean that is one
major thing i learned from that
well yeah being poorer is very hard a
nightmare by the way you know that i
wrote on the top of my list of questions
for you
uh
natasha legero has the best laugh in
comedy and has single-handedly kept
mediocre comedians doing comedy much
longer than they should what does that
mean just because of your laugh because
if you laugh oh cause i'm laughing just
you have this amazing laugh and it's
probably encouraged so many mediocre
guys to keep doing comedy live guys
i mean it's not a fake laugh no i don't
think it's fake at all but if like you
get one i mean
i
derived so much self-worth from if you
like if you laugh at something it really
keeps people going
that's a nice way i know it's a really
nice thing to say you're showering me
with gifts i know i'm comfortable i'm
the best who do you get relationship
advice from you're someone that gives
relationship advice a lot on your
podcast who do you get it from who do
you go to
um
uh well i started seeing a couple's
therapist because you know the pandemic
were you kind of a did you have a
boyfriend during the pandemic i had a
yes i had a lover not a live-in
situation
everything was like living
i know i just feel like you know i
emotion i never fought and
then all of a sudden like having because
we were always like gone like you know
he was on the road
i was on the road yeah you know it was
like
yeah good space and then all of a sudden
it's like this person is next to you
like drinking their chips
from a bag like and i know it's like you
must have done this before because you
have a straw like what else or you know
in the crumbs yeah like just like just
it was like oh
i can't do this like i i didn't know
this was part of it but you know it's
just
honestly it's the pandemic i i really
think it's really more sanitary and i
would rather someone no that would
trigger chips it was just like the ease
with which he was just like
you know just like drinking it and it
was just like oh this is what goes on
when i'm in
you know albany albany but here's what
i'll say
i can't stand things that
are so crazy that the person that calls
them out seems crazy so i have a thing
where if you have a bag of chips and you
you put it on a plate and you eat the
chips when someone is putting their hand
in chips over and over again i'm like do
you not hear how loud like how do you
not with that would you deal with
drinking them
like the let the end of the bag i
i am uh i do drink my cereal milk and
that's different i
uh
[Music]
what kind of chips
i'm sorry that matters
very flavorful like flavor bomb like
probably trying to eat the end like this
like the onion the bugle the the salsa
verde
doritos special eat pretzels i do
lick my finger and eat the salt at the
end
um
well you know what let's not ever live
together
during our next pandemic it's i
is it the noise or is it just the like
desperation say it's the entire package
whitney gotta gotta go get it
it's the tableau yeah yeah i'm a child
and also it's happening in bed person
no eating in bed absolutely is that is
that see now jessie wilson and her
husband eat full meals in the bed i
don't get it well we used to have bed
picnics and that was fun pre-pandemic
it's like oh downton abbey's on let's
order indian food and like set up a
picnic like i'm okay with that
but you don't i don't want my bed to
smell like not i know what you mean how
can you do this this is so out of
character well you know that was those
were the old days crumbs in the bed
i know well i would i would put a whole
blanket out i would like do like it over
the yes okay and like little like you
know like little um bed trays
but anyway
uh
couples therapy helps i think um
how does it help
well you know they tell you good stuff
and also it's it's nice it's nice to
like bring something up to a third party
like before you even tell the person
although the other day
we had a couple's therapy appointment
and we had had a fight like two nights
before and then we had we totally made
up we had an amazing anniversary i know
and then we had couples therapy and it
was just like he just unleashed it and i
was just sitting there
and then he was like well i and
afterwards i go i i can't believe all
this stuff and he's like well you know i
just wanted to make sure that i didn't
forget everything so i made a list you
know and he's like i just because i
always forget because everything's
always good when you're taught so you
know i was kind of blindsided by that
but i i but i do it so i'm okay to like
bring things up to a third party i think
that can be very helpful i just feel
like scheduling it in advance like well
we're not in a fight today and then like
well three months ago and you're like i
know that's the problem mark maron used
to have the funniest joke i remember
because i used to open for him and like
la jolla and stuff you have to pick up
his cat somewhere
you know what i did not um but i do
remember one night this was actually i
think the funniest shit i've ever seen
him do we he was on stage in la jolla he
was going through like a divorce it was
an intense time and he got to the point
where he's like sitting on the stage
he'd gone for like an hour and a half it
was like la jolla the second show starts
at 10 it was like midnight and he said
like if you guys want to go you can
leave but i'm gonna keep going and like
half the people got up and left and he
just kept going
because he wanted to do like two hours
just this is not going to end anytime
soon if you guys want to head out good
for him and
i'm not this isn't really about comedy
anymore i'm just trying to kind of like
i'm like the opposite i'm like i'm going
to be doing 20 minutes less and you can
have your money back but
i'm leaving
um
where am i going with this couples
therapy oh yeah it's like if you said
that mark had like oh yeah about he just
had a joke about it at the time like
scheduling when you go
into couples every and you leave and you
have to get the car together and you're
like what the fuck was that like just
how instantly right now it zooms you're
like nuzzled up next to each other like
right and you're just like and it's like
well she did this two months ago and
you're like what the fuck like are you
doing you know it's just sort of like
where did that come from
you know so to me it's like as someone
that is trying to like
ease out of therapy i feel like i maybe
have over therapized slightly um
i do think though for a lot of people
individual therapy is sometimes
if you're not working on your own shit
just coming to the couple's therapist is
like well
that's because you're rigid and you know
codependent in this but you have to take
care of that separately like this person
can't fix our childhoods right now
exactly but but you know they can they
can really help you work on the
relationship like just the other day she
said to us she said well because he you
know there's all these issues how you
want the other person to be yeah she's
like well what about thinking about the
kind of partner you want to be and just
being that way
and i feel like you know just trying to
make that shift a little bit
healthy like would you want to be
married to you right because you know i
and i and i do feel like i don't know do
you do you feel like this like i just
feel like since the pandemic like i i
really am having a hard time
keeping my buoyancy
i i feel like and i don't know if women
are absorbing more of the trauma but i
just feel like i'm kind of in mourning
for the world in a way like i mean i'm
still very selfish obviously but i just
feel like i
i'm just feeling very heavy and
um
i just feel like you know if this was a
history book it's like okay now we've
just started this yeah like you know
like we're on that like but that's very
negative but i don't know how to like
get past it is this um do you feel like
do you consume a lot of news
it's more like a feeling
are you an emp like like i know that's
such a like
maybe i have like apology words over
active empathy or something
i don't know
you know for me if i'm in new york
with i'll walk five blocks and then and
be emotional and just be cr like i will
i get emotional just walk around new
york city because i will absorb other
people's like sadness and i just take it
on it's like you it's almost like you
don't even need to yes that too but then
look around you i mean go drive down
hollywood boulevard it's like there's
homeless people everywhere yeah
stores are closed down like you know
i just feel like but the irony and the
rich people are getting richer we're all
addicted to our phones like something's
like not like it just feels very
dark to me yeah i'm not exactly sure how
to just pretend like it's not but maybe
it was it was going to be this bad
before the pandemic and it's someone
that is uh like a
to a fault like
devil's advocate just because i don't
like my brain just does that i'm not
happy about it it's like my fatal flaw
but
you know as horrific as it's been it
also they're saying that the only reason
the ozone layer is going to heal in any
capacity is because all of us being shut
down and it was just sort of like the
environment that's a nice way of looking
at it yeah i mean it was like for
people to stop driving and planes to
stop flying for a year is like the only
way we would have any kind of healing of
the environment in any capacity you know
so it's like
that is
i don't know my brain always has to like
go to
find some like positive so that i don't
and spiral what's the positive to my
child being masked and not under not
seeing expressions or i guess for me
what what i've seen is someone that is
not a parent and doesn't understand at
all i think that as i've watched so many
of my friends mourn their child children
in masks and they're on zoom and they're
not socializing in person and stuff like
that i think that we have this like
narcissistic need to make our
offspring have the exact same
life we had i think that they are being
well prepared for their future
they are
by the way forever which is the end of
civilization so end times you know not
like or not because if
let's be honest none of us need to be
driving to those interviews and
auditions all day so if zooming a little
bit more and being on your phone instead
of like driving and seeing each other in
person like kids are having sex way
later they're doing way less drugs
they're doing way less destructive
dangerous things like kids i mean i yes
i do have a whole thing about this so
i've thought you should write a book on
on motherhood with before you have kids
i'm just saying i just you know what if
you guys would just listen to me as
someone that has never had a child but
that's but i feel like it's helpful
because i can actually be
like have some perspective on it is that
people like kids are on their phones all
day it's like okay we were on
merry-go-rounds and see saws and falling
off of monkey bars i mean they basically
like duct taped us into the car like
there was no like car seats like i just
feel like everything is just that's
something everything is safer now kids
are safer than they've ever been like
the the the negative trends that we
experienced are completely reversing
with them the idea it's like they don't
go out and socialize okay they're not
going to get pink eye and headlights
like who gives a shit like how is that
like right i believe that progress is
progressive if you find whitney you're
right i'm just saying i don't think it's
as bad as we think i think that we've
gotten a little bit spoiled and number
one we want them to like what we want
them to play twister
like you're going to mars aren't you i'm
not i'm good
i'm i am going to toledo
next week
whitney cummings whitney that tour is
intense it's very intense oh my god you
should be the first comedian to go to
mars i'm
shatner just go to mars
okay no
i already have enough
cbs drama um
uh i i i don't think i think that it's a
natural proclivity for a parent to like
look at how much better they can parent
and i think that's positive and that's
why we've evolved to you know be
that's your superpower to be hyper
vigilant but i also think that like
our without phones was we used to walk
around the mall for five hours with no
money and just like flirt with men and
shoplift like you know i'm saying like i
don't i used to play a game where we
were like let's shoplift into in the
seventh store like we would like pick a
number i remember claire's boutique like
eau claire's putting rings in my mouth
i
used to put toe rings in my mouth you
put them in your mouth too i stole from
natural bridge in west virginia and
guess what i stole native american
jewelry
already stolen stuff i stole you know
how fucked up that is you really put the
thing in your mouth oh yeah i put little
um uh turquoise like horses in my mouth
yeah it was just fun to figure out how
we could steal benton used to work at
sephora and he said that the way women
shop lift lipstick is they turn it up
and bite off the top and leave with it
in their mouth
by the way we used to have we used to
share
an agent
i won't say who but he said is it bs yes
he wasn't an agent what was he he was
like an assistant okay well anyway he he
which by the way whenever i would call
and be like hey can i get an audition he
go you want me to get your job in the
mail room wait he was an assistant he
was like an assistant he wasn't even a
real agent okay well he told me he used
to be
he used to be security at sephora and
would just let people leave with stuff
he was also a security guard at sephora
while he was
to be very clear every time i called it
was it didn't
sound busy i'm like what is that why is
groove theory playing in the background
um okay yes but you're supposed to let
them go you're not allowed to stop them
physically oh really benton explained
why you're supposed to just let them go
because if you touch them it's illegal
for someone so then what do you do
what's the point of knowing them
they just uh uh benton
said that one time so people will
shoplift uh or they'll buy something and
then return it and when someone returns
something you have to open it and check
it and one time this woman returned
lemaire like the most expensive cream
you can buy and he opened it and smelled
it and went ma'am this is mayonnaise
for real she had filled it with
mayonnaise so so people will buy creams
they'll take the cream out and then
refill it what instincts how would he
even think of that because they all have
to because it's so common like the way
he talks about the and women would
shoplift with their toes they would like
just steal stuff with their toes and
then put it in their shoes like and you
would just watch it and let them go wow
yeah you can't confront them about it
because of some like law
well i feel very blessed that i never
got arrested and i'm glad that that was
a phase and i'm not i'm i'm i'm a little
ashamed of it
when i was a kid there were kids would
have casts that went from the foot to
the dick i mean there were cats with
metal bars like kids were getting
injured in a way that i don't see kids
in casts any like i don't see it people
are like they're on their phone too much
it's like okay
we had i mean
my high school like the li it was like a
world war ii movie there were
there were um crutches kids would like
once this time you saw a kid on crutches
right or with any kind of
injury
we would like fall off monkey bars and
like jungle we would climb 50 feet in
the air and like hang upside down off
monkey bars but but how do we know that
that by you know helicoptering around
and hovering around our children that
they're gonna turn out better
i don't think they i don't i just i just
in general think that they're safer than
they've ever been but it's our instinct
to always look for danger so there's no
like not as much
actual danger like kids aren't falling
out of tree houses and all the kind of
like fucked up shit that we did and
we ate glue and stuff like that now kids
are just like playing fruit ninja you
know and we're like it's they're not as
social but i think in general in person
contact is going to be less and less so
i think that the zoom school and all
that kind of stuff is probably going to
make the kids better adapted for the
world they're going to live in yeah
because viruses and panda this is going
to just keep happening in different
iterations
cool
but we're gonna adapt you know what i'm
saying it was like in the beginning cars
didn't have seat belts and there were
more car accidents than there are now
and then we'll have self-driving cars so
less people are gonna die in accidents
like it will fix itself you know but i
think that watching so many parents
first of all the the thing that was
really
embarrassing to watch is when the
pandemic happened like a couple months
in people like i have to zoom with my
kids and it's so stressful and it's so
hard and it's like so you just hung out
with your kid you find you fuck so
that's what teachers have to deal with
500 of those motherfuckers every day
like you just met your child and
realized your kid's a dickhead you know
it was like watching parents complain
about that was like
odd and then and i i it's just i think
that we're over pathologizing
this amazing no you're right and i and i
think it's very miracle
you can find internet
yeah you can find your kid whenever you
want we didn't we left school and like
i know walked home i know just in the
dark
well i didn't do that but maybe that's
because yeah in dc in washington dc i
would walk home like it was like
i just feel like it's uh it's wildly
less dangerous but it's you know we're
wired to look for danger and only look
for the negative which is why we
proliferate as a species but i think we
are
it's probably just hard to see well i
think that's very
good to look at the positive whitney and
you disagree no i i agree with you and i
think you know for
for me in particular like even though it
was hard on my relationship i think for
our family unit it was really healthy
and like i mean we had dinner
seven nights a week together and had
conversation
you know i would have like had someone
helping me probably 50 hours a week and
those were 50 hours i was spending with
my child but it made us you know just
because i was work that's the problem
it's like as a woman if you want to have
a career you have to kind of you know
hire people to help you or you can't do
it all that's right so you know i
always often say is better for the kid
too because the more
primary caretakers they have the better
like like children are we are wired to
be in a village and have aunts and
grandmas and a bunch of women taking
care the whole thing of like
one woman taking care of her child is
like
wildly new and most cultures don't do it
and we're supposed to have sisters and
like we're not all supposed to be on
different coasts and have our mom on one
coast
we're all supposed to be in one place
and we've changed that so it's like the
same thing with food allergies and stuff
it's like we've evolved to be able to
digest certain foods
our body hasn't caught up to like flying
bananas from florida to portland you
know it's sort of like we're sort of
made to eat the things which is why when
you eat local honey your allergies get
better because it's like we're just
wired to be able to digest the things
that are in our proximity i think the
same thing with
kids where women are supposed to have
help
yeah that's help is good yeah and kids
are supposed to just socialize with
other kids in the family but there's no
way that kids today have not been
hearing like morbid talk you know it's
very hard to shield them like my child
who's three said to me the day she's
like mom can we be buried in the same
graveyard
and i just feel like
i try not to talk about like i was like
like i was like don't ever
talk about dying or like the nanny kept
talking about coronavirus i was like can
we please not talk about this in front
of her but then it's like do i shelter
her now it's like you know she tried to
kiss her friend on the lips the other
day and i was at soccer and i was like
no like from the sidelines and she
looked at me like her whole face fell
and she didn't understand what she did
wrong and you know i just feel like
there's just a lot of
psychic
even though she's only three maybe she
won't remember it but it's just like a
lot of this like don't do that don't do
that you know and and i'm trying to like
temper it but it's still it's like i
don't know it's it's just it's really
hard but everything's hard
but i just feel bad that they're so like
you know they're so in touch with death
i guess i mean i i saw old yeller when i
was like five
you know what i'm saying i mean i i just
i just feel like if you had older
siblings all you heard was i'm gonna
kill you you're adopted you're not a
real you know what i'm saying like i
just i feel like i got so much of that i
watched tom and jerry i mean i used to
like hit people with hammers like from
watching cartoons you know what i'm
saying like i guess i just
and also all of them like lying about
easter bunny and santa i think a lot of
the stuff that we think is okay
at least in my experience was weirdly
traumatic and all the things that i
think everyone assumed would be
traumatic was weirdly fine
does that make any sense yes like i
think i think you're right i was like
some of the most trauma i had as a kid
was not even like
falling or hurting myself or like having
you know
whatever all the weird shit i did and
the things i ate and whatever but uh was
like hearing that wait didn't you tell
me that you when you were little you
went when i was like you found like
value i ate yeah i ate like basically
it was basically like a percocet it was
like 500 milligrams of like percocet and
i ate it and like flatlined and they had
to put charcoal down my throat to get it
out
like a poison control oh my god yeah and
like it there's def but
i definitely remember almost drowning
wow like just like the parent like in an
above ground pool like i remember like
trying to gasp for air and they were all
like having fun and i i think it was
just but here's what i'll say i think
that's marjorie
when you look back at all of the things
that really were like snapchat like i
remember one of the most traumatic
things that i've ever that happened to
me at least that left a mark was being
at a friend's house
at their pool i was probably like seven
or eight and i was a chubby kid i was
chubby you were yeah i was chubby i'll
show you pictures until i was like 11 or
12 and then i got an eating disorder
thank god like an adult um and i
remember this woman i was eating grapes
and she was like you know that grapes
are the most high calorie fruit
it was obviously an
older woman with eating issues and she
wouldn't let me have remember those
magic middles um keebler elves it was
like a cookie with like chocolate like
fudge inside and i ate like two and she
was like you can't have any more and
this was someone else like my mom wasn't
there it was a parent you know what i'm
saying it was like you never know she
said that because you were chubby
because i was chubby and i was like
eating too much and she was and then she
said the best uh there was like ketchup
and she was like oh the lowest calorie
condiment is mustard you should always
put mustard on your food this was
obviously a woman that was traumatized
in whatever way and had issues with her
body who cares but like the way that she
accidentally kind of
did damage my mother could never have
controlled my father like no one i just
feel like there's a point where you're
like i don't know i'm such in a place of
like adversity all the things that
really hurt me made me stronger like
looking back and i feel very grateful
for all my adversity because i think it
gave me a lot of superpowers that a lot
of my friends that had like very gentle
delicate attentive
perfect childhoods oh my kid's gonna be
fucked
why because i'm like always like i'm
like always trying to create like this
like narnia atmosphere around her and
like you know making sure like like like
moshe and i like we love her so much
like we'll fight over like who gets to
like come into her room in the morning
he's like i was gonna do it and i'm like
i don't want to do it like
like we just sound prepared
we just like her so much and love her so
much and it's like i didn't have that i
mean i know my parents loved me but like
they certainly weren't like knocking
each other out of the way so they could
like wake her up from her nap she's
gonna be incredibly well adjusted she's
just not gonna be as successful as you
but she'll be fine with it
i do find i just wanted to compost
whitney yeah look i i feel like and have
a podcast she's gonna be in such a
radically different world i mean i
people that are four years younger than
me i feel like they're 50 years younger
than me like you know what i'm saying i
feel like the generations are getting
tighter and tighter it used to be like
every 10 years there would be kind of a
difference in people now i feel like
it's so quick
right like there's a new dating app i
was talking to someone i was like oh is
it hinge and they're like no it's like
bopple or whatever and i was just like
when did that start and like it's just
so quick that someone two years younger
than me that feels like 10 years younger
than me now that her life whatever's
happening for her i do feel like is
preparing her for the reality she's
going to live in that we can't even
conceive at the moment
you know yeah i mean maybe masks are
kind of here to stay
hand washing and sanitizer is like here
to stay you know all these things that i
think
you know look we had
i like i think about when like we had a
little cloth mask like we had
metal fish hooks like barbed wire and i
would roll over and like impale my neck
wait we slept in that headgear slept in
barbed wire
hats
the cloth masks are probably fine
i remember that like
they just phased that i mean speaking of
doctors taking photos and just slipping
them into a random drawer i feel like
that i've not seen a kid in headgear
since
yeah i don't know maybe they've stopped
that was just an s m like straight up
sex game it was never there's no way we
had to wear half a basketball hoop in
our mouth there's just no way with like
a scrunchie
[Music]
oh that's great that's great bro hell
where is the wicked movie so hiring
okay we're back to ants
brook linen i love brook linen which i
would much rather be in my bed in my
brook linen because it's hard to leave
it's so hard to leave that i just
started taking it with us on the road
smart yeah so i have uh this is me
harassing whitney about my brooklyn
because i do need more of it so chop
whitney let's take a look this is
brooklyn and i wanted to come show you
let me fill it see that's how you know
it's brooklyn
take it off right now i'll show you i'm
gonna show you all the ways is my shirt
my shirt is not broken do you see this
and i'm still look at this
i'm so comfortable
because i have them for clinton
can i tell you something these sheets
are not brooklyn and it's a bummer it is
a bummer that's why i brought this shirt
because it feels like i'm wearing the
sheets at all times can you take that
shirt off and put it on my pillowcase so
i can pretend i have brooklyn sheets
i think that brook linen has made you
too comfortable i think you're too
comfortable do you know how you're just
storming in when i'm trying to sleep
that's too comfortable sheets loungewear
candles another sheets literally that
was me barging into whitney's hotel room
to show her all the ways i could use my
brooklyn because i was so excited about
it because i got the lounge set in and
it's incredible and you know what
there's no such thing as too much
comfort and if you could use a little
more you're in luck brooklyn's biggest
sale of the year is here which means
serious savings on essentials for
creating your dream space this cell is
big news for comfort brooklyn's entire
site of super soft seriously cozy
essentials are on sale right now
shopping doesn't get any easier than
brooklyn and bundles save more when you
stock up with essentials for your space
now's the time to get gifting with deals
on items for everyone on your list
whether you're shopping cents for a
candle lover or grabbing a gift card aka
the gift that keeps on giving this kind
of holiday comfort is always a hit for
the holiday don't miss out brooklyn's
biggest sale of the year is here
listening after the
you still can save visit
brooklyn.com and use promo code whitney
for 20 off with a minimum purchase of a
hundred dollars okay well you ruined
that but uh that's
b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com
promo code whitney
that was great um so i couldn't help but
notice during that brooklyn and addie
were in whitney's hotel room do you
barge in on her a lot
i
but sometimes i'm not always ready for
what i find oh god so i did happen to i
wanted to barge in bring her um
you know like a drink i was like i got
these drinks for us nobody
chat right and when i broke in right uh
this is what i found it's me
chalker i know that you are um
pretending to be tired but i want to
show people i want to show people what
you what you travel with
why because people are interested in
that oh
oh this is old
crackers disgusting okay
don't touch my stuff what is this why do
you have lube
do you have lube are you traveling with
lube
where is the
lube stay out of my business where are
that what you're putting on your face
instead of uh grape seed oil
no i might get lucky
literally you've been putting this what
have you been doing with this are you
putting that on your nipples before
showing your business it looks like
nipple juice no this is lube it has cbd
in it
and
yeah sometimes i will put it on my
nether regions and hump the stool while
i'm on stage your intimate areas
no i haven't cause so you know might get
lucky my guy might come with me on tour
that look i want that stool to slip in
though
here's the thing
i gotta be honest i'm 39
in my day you just didn't have orgasms
it just wasn't it wasn't really a thing
he had an orga but in the butt and then
i realized like oh
that's an option and then i didn't know
how and then you got to have the lube
with the cbd and it relaxes you chills
you out because the key to
i mean this is so dirty to say right now
i'm so tired and i'm on a sleeping pill
and you know that and you're taking
advantage of me but i think this is a
good lube for you to travel with because
when they see it they go oh it's from
her apothecary
it's from my apothecary yeah and they
just let you go right on through it okay
you're a pussycarry you get what you get
and you don't get upset when you dig
through other people's belongings
you found your boss's loop yeah for the
seventh or eighth time yeah too bad over
an hr department now i'm in the hr
department oh i have to talk to you
who is fouria who fouria is using all
natural and plant-based ingredients to
intensify sexual pleasure and relieve
discomfort phoria has a serious cult
following with tens of thousands of
people who have had their sex lives
transformed through using their products
and they have really cool products you
know they have um lube
capsules that you like insert and they
dissolve inside of you so you're ready
when you're ready i didn't know that
yeah so yes you have whitney's
permission to try this she fully
endorses you go ahead and treat yourself
to more deeper fuller pleasure wherever
you can find it and as often as possible
you can start with a balaphoria fourier
is offering a special deal for our
listeners get twenty percent off your
first order by visiting fourier wellness
dot com slash whitney or use code
whitney at checkout that's f o r i a
wellness dot com forward slash whitney
for twenty percent off your first order
i recommend trying their awaken arousal
oil and sex oil you'll thank me later
it's euphoria
get it euphoria yeah i got it okay
their products are really cool though
they really are and now back to this
euphoric interview between two badass
ladies ooh
nailed it natasha and wishnet we should
head back now go go back back to the
interview
come on go back i do feel like
like whatever it's not the world that we
want to live in like we don't want to
wear masks all day but the sooner they
get desensitized to it the less
traumatic it's going to be i think it's
traumatic for us but not necessarily for
them because they don't know anything
else do you think
yeah
is that crazy no no i mean i hear you i
mean it also depends on your kid like my
kid's extremely social so she would just
be like staring out the window for a
year and a half being like high window
you know and and not other kids
other kids
pink eye but now she gets to you know
socialize a little bit yeah even though
she's you know wearing a mask sometimes
so yeah you know my thing is for
anyone's behavior during the pandemic
drop the charges we were all like in
fight or flight mode were bleeding a lot
i
barely survived i discovered edibles
i didn't brush my hair i mean i looked
like courtney love for a couple months
what you discovered edibles during this
yes i had never really done anything
what's your what's your takeaway um well
are you still a fan still have a giant
bump on the side of my head for passing
out on that wall
you passed out from the edibles uh yes
so we were on an ig live benton and i i
took the blueberries which are
it is russian roulette because do you
know how many milligrams
i think they're like five or ten and i
that's not a lot but i love i i just
thought it was like eating blueberries
oh so you took probably like five or six
because my thing with edibles is i get
too impatient and i'll take one and i'm
like this isn't working and then i'll do
i'm like i got a dud well when you go to
amsterdam they tell you like they have
those space cakes and they're like
apparently like everyone who
like a very common thing in amsterdam is
people jumping out of windows because
they take half of the space cake nothing
happens they're tourists they eat the
rest of it they go crazy it is kind of a
slow
it sucks it's like you don't want to be
high in three and a half hours you're
chill you're chill then you're like
on another planet yeah for me like i
just think that with the waiting and
then my brain i can pretty much do
everything i just because of stand-up
like i've just never really drank i've
never really done drugs like it's just
like we work at night you know yeah but
also it's the one job where people are
like can i get you a drink would you
like i know we like some weed can we i
mean people are like pro like trying to
apply you with alcohol from the second
you get there so yeah and i feel like
that's but in la you have to drive like
in new york you can walk from spot to
spot but for me it was always like i'm
gonna go to another spot or i have to
drive somewhere you know and i just i
guess i just i grew up around so much
alcoholism that by the time i was an
adult i was like dude if you just don't
drink you can get twice as much done so
my workaholism always a clipped and
eclipsed any desire for like a substance
well you know yourself very well yeah i
did feel like you have really good
therapists
thank you
that is so funny she's amazing she must
have great therapist well you just feel
very like self-aware and you know
happy and people you're looking at
something i mean you've known me right
from pre-therapy days it wasn't great
but you're also not a judgmental person
i think you you tend to see the best in
everyone and you keep a very safe
healthy distance from people hmm
you don't agree
i mean i like that you think that you
said once something that the reason i
rationalize as not being close friends
is that you keep a safe healthy distance
from people so if this isn't true i feel
rejected you said want something that
blew my mind you were waitressing and
doing stand-up and then i think maybe
shooting something and i remember
i was like always trying to have girls
nights and like develop all these like
female friendships before i was really
at a place where i was able to have
healthy friendships and they'd be very
entrenched and
um you know because the codependence is
this over developed sense of
responsibility thing and this like one
too many a million not enough addict
thinking we can't just be friends we
have to be best friends and we're like i
could not leave a party without plans to
go on a hike it was like i could not
do it i could not it's like coffee bean
the coffee bean like it was just hike
after hike and i i wasn't able to go
like oh this isn't one of my people you
know because you've got your people
people you vibrate with that bring out
the best in your okay so what did i say
i gotta know you said you you said
something and this is gonna sound savage
but
it really hit me because i was running
myself ragged martyring myself on
friendships i didn't even want to be in
you know like you're like fine i'll go
to coffee with her and then after coffee
she's gonna go to hike and you're like
oh i thought this coffee was gonna take
care of it but the more you see the
person the more you know what i mean
you said
i said something like
about friendships and you're like i just
don't have time for a lot of friendships
you just said i don't have time and i
was like
i didn't realize that had anything to do
with it i thought you make time and then
contort yourself to make the person like
you and like i just i didn't realize you
had a choice in the matter
you know what i'm saying i did the idea
of like putting yourself first or the
idea of like going what's funny is you
could tell me i said anything and i have
no memories you said it in a way that
was it didn't sound bitchy it just
sounded so
well i think when you're trying to come
up and you're trying to transcend your
class like i was trying to do i had to
kind of like let some things fall by the
wayside but i would definitely like some
more friends now yeah but i feel like i
would but like i had no business being
friends with half the people i was quote
friends with it was just codependent
attachments and i was like running
myself ragged trying to have all these
like friendships that were
honestly a lot of people are really
toxic it was just like a huge waste of
time and um
it it made a big impact on me because it
was like oh like put yourself first like
oh like
sleep eight hours instead of like
hanging out with this person you don't
even like that much i would like dread
like those texts or phone calls when
someone calls you like oh god like what
am i gonna say to get out of this you
know i just thought that was a normal
friendship
wow i know
like i would like how many friends do
you have now
ah emily
the ones i pay count
no
i don't think payroll counts
i have i think
you know i did this attachment course
with george haas about sort of like
you've got your a's your b's and your
c's and your a's are you connect three
times a week those are like your a
friendships the people that you go to
like co-regulate with and like invest in
a big way and then you've got your b's
which are like twice a month and your
c's that are like acquaintances and you
put people
in kind of a hierarchy in a good way as
a way to
um make sure you're valuing the right
one and investing in the right ones
essentially and um
so i'm really big on
very close friendships like few or close
friendships and then
acquaintances that sort of stay
acquaintances like i'm able to have a
lot of friendships where i can like
talk to you
once a month
well i also think that you know it was
easier
when there was a stand-up scene because
then it was like i was so fulfilled
every time every night i was like oh i
love this guy i love her i can talk to
people we're socializing we're having
these huge laughs we're connecting we're
catching up and then leaving and then i
would never talk to them again until the
next show i saw them at and like i i was
always like extremely grateful for that
aspect of stand-up because that was
you know just made it seem like you just
had this amazing circuit of the funniest
smartest people it gets built damaged
but funny
every night and you're not falling
behind or having to sacrifice work i
think it's like i feel now i don't
really know what's happening that's
really interesting i know and i do feel
like i mean something kind of wild
happened when the pandemic started which
is like
a lot of comedians started like turning
on each other and it was like such a
weird like oh
like was all of that pretend like were
you know
well no that's why like you know there's
so many
fights breaking out people are very
aggro people have been
people can't afford therapy people don't
go to therapy you know you also have
bifurcated news so people are also
getting a different set of information
depending on where they get their news
most people and this is another part of
the
you know end of civilization i mean i'm
glad that you're thinking
you know
positively about it but this is also a
part of it yeah i mean the the the
fascinating thing i mean colin quinn did
a special about this
i think it aired on cnn about how
america should just break into two
countries because it is getting to the
point to where
no fault of their own if you watch a
certain network and can and have a
certain algorithm like you don't even
have access
to accurate information you know and
it's like you don't know what you don't
know so i actually have a lot of
sympathy for the people that are just
like i have family members that
uh are operating with a different set of
facts than i am and you can you and
people they're stupid it's like they're
not stupid they just are like reading
fiction books and it's being presented
to them as fact you know and
that's or that is what you know i think
that in our lifetime we will see the
same way tobacco has been regulated the
same way alcohol is regulated the same
way you have to take a test and i think
there's going to be an access to the
internet thing that is going to change i
mean this idea that like
anyone can put anything on any news site
and it looks true
and there's a statistic that if people
see something more than four times they
think it's true because it's on many
different publications right and it's
like oh it must be true because all
these people ran it you know and now
everyone is addicted to the phone that's
what the pandemic did yeah so
i don't know it just seems
things like remember that bill hicks
joke i always thought about it cause he
was like everyone's saying it's the end
of the world this was like 20 years ago
everyone's always thought that and he's
like and he's like but then you go
outside and the birds are chirping but
it's like now you go outside and it's
like oh the everyone's in masks and all
these places shut down and everyone's on
their phone so it does kind of seem like
it's happening people were afraid of
elevators when they first started coming
into buildings because they thought that
they were going to get electrocuted like
standing in it because like it's
obviously metal and conducted and they
thought that was like the end of the
world you know it's like it is very
normal for humans to be terrified of new
technology that's the unknown people
were terrified of trains they thought
that trains you know like conducting
with the electricity would electrocute
them a lot of people didn't go on trains
so it's like there's always been
two ta like paranoid people that are
like this technology is going to hurt us
whereas i do believe especially if i may
as women that have to
on average especially moms have to do
more
in less amount of time i do think the
robots we're so scared of are gonna help
us as someone that like lost two parents
to strokes like i do think like robotic
surgeons and
you know better technology for surgery
and detect like this is all going to
help us but i think that why you're such
a great comedian is the same reason that
on some level you need anti-depressants
no you observe things that you and you
know you see we see the darkness and
everything you know and that's why
you're funny you get to go on you know
it's like why you're a brilliant roaster
and a brilliant comedian as you're
always going to see the thing that a lot
of people don't notice because you don't
have that ignorance as bliss thing
you're just too smart and i think it's
something that's like served us really
well but sometimes it can be
bleak the way that our brains work it's
just taking me a long time to just go
like and i've studied because i did this
whole thing on robots and
studying the history of humans
terror of you know obviously um uh i
think you actually talked about on your
podcast uh at some point the uncanny
valley why we're so afraid of dolls and
so afraid of robots is like we are wired
essentially to be uh recoil at something
men more so than women for obvious
reasons uh recoil at anything that looks
human but doesn't move like a human i.e
something that looks human but could be
sick or dead it's called pathogen
avoidance it's basically we evolved to
do it so that men didn't fuck corpses
that's why they're and get weird
diseases that's the the men that were
most afraid of so
dude if you are any if you're afraid of
robots that meant your ancestors fucked
dead women
full stop
wait don't you have a robot i do and so
i learned a lot about this wait can i
see it or is it you is no
thank you
she is at the shop getting aged up
because she was made almost two years
ago and looks younger than me and
instead of me like there's one other
person uh that has a robot that looks
exactly like him he's in japan
um i was gonna say obviously but emily
would cut it um and he gets plastic
surgery to look like the robot and that
feels like a
a slippery slope so she's getting like
crow's feet and some wrinkles and
also
the reason that robots are not going to
evolve as fast as everyone's so afraid
of is because robots make robots so
until men until women start getting in
the robotics industry
uh and humanizing the faces because men
can't read faces the same way women can
therefore that's why these robots just
look like fucking cartoon chucky dolls
because there are no women getting into
robotics so until women are in robotics
they're not going to evolve in a way
that's actually going to be like
realistic so
um so
she
i said oh can we get her eyebrows like
real hair eyebrows
and because i think men have never
noticed eyebrows or seen them before or
whatever they just took hair from a wig
and put it like two hitler mustaches
above and there were long hairs that
they just moved this way i was like you
gotta go back to one on this like this
looks insane and she's gonna get
cameras for eyeballs
and what are you doing with this
you know
you had a child
and i didn't judge that
uh it was an experiment that was like
supposed to just be a disaster i was
just gonna have it made i thought it was
just gonna look like a shitty scarecrow
it was just gonna be funny
and then she ended up she was gorgeous
and she had talent because she by the
way she's a star and she ended up being
really good and it was just basically i
had been told by netflix we can get
people to start specials we can't get
them to finish them so can you please do
something at the end of the special that
even if people walk away and go i'll
finish the rest later they actually come
back so i was like all right
i think i got my
gimmick
well i'm excited to see her when she
gets back are you
kind of i mean but i just want to tune
into stories i just mean humans have
always been afraid of technology and
it's always for the most part benefited
us except for like teflon and all the
stuff that gave us cancer um but there
are rehabs opening up for cell phone
addiction which is really fascinating
well you know i hope you're right
whitney in the 50s we were just addicted
to rose and pills if not i'll just uh
i'll just drink this poison you got me i
think
i think the phone is the least bad
addiction all right all right and when
you get a lot of work done do you want
to go back to phone calls
i want to i want to go back to not just
having two hours go by where i'm just
like refreshing my screen
you want to be present
well i it it it doesn't make me feel
good
it it it's it's sort of like um
it's like the opposite of feeling you
know it just makes me it's like torpor
it's like it's like it's like i'm i'm
like
receding as opposed to like because
you're yeah because your tolerance gets
um higher and higher for dopamine i did
want to ask you i have so many questions
uh uh
your podcast has such incredible guests
i love the relationship advice i love
hear hearing your brain work um i love
the secret section it's very cathartic
and kind of um
great for the adrenaline junkies out
there so if you just got sober this is
your pod um i do
uh by the way i did just another period
i hadn't watched the last season it is
on amazon prime did you know that it's
on amazon
apple i think i know you're super power
whitney you better be getting checks
what how do you know all this
you just have like endless
energy time
because i'm childless
well i did not know that i do work hard
to prepare for the guests i season three
is on amazon prime on amazon prime now
yes
interesting yes i think comedy central
is now a.net
i'm not sure what's going on over there
um but no i especially when it's people
that i care about i cannot stand when i
go to podcast at this point and
someone's like so how'd you get to
comedy i'm like i've answered this like
you can't do this to me or like where do
we find your thing you tell me i don't
know i really appreciate it and i hope
that you come on our podcast i would i
would love to i thought i thought we
were gonna try to do that i don't know
what happened i'm sure it was my fault
um i did want to ask you a couple things
number one wait i did not know you had a
degree in theater criticism is that true
well i went to state school because
that's what i could afford because i
paid for it and in i was in new york and
i wanted to get a degree and from the
city university of new york it was
either tech theater or theater criticism
so they didn't have an for some reason i
couldn't get an acting degree so
i took theater criticism but i was
really good at it and i like won an
award and it was like basically a great
transition into comedy because it was
just critiquing society sure
that's so
yes that's what my do you still go see
plays all the well i haven't lately but
i
yes and moshe loves to do that as well
so we'll always get season tickets to
like any i mean la doesn't have
as many right right things but um but
yeah here ucla griffin the griffin or
whatever
the get
the griffin's a bar most things are
called gethin in l.a
um yes i've seen a couple plays there
plays make me uncomfortable a lot you
don't like plays i just get
uncomfortable
i don't know why
well you know what really helps i found
is going alone
because then you don't feel guilty that
someone else is like not enjoying it
sure but is that how people feel when
they come see comedy
see i like to see comedy alone too
because you don't want pressure to have
to like exactly or like i mean now it's
different i have a comedian husband so
you know to me doesn't like come
watching ice skating where i'm like
don't fall don't fall like i get very
nervous for the person maybe it's
because i'm a performer and i can't just
release
and although i did watch jag a little
pill on a bootleg video loved it um but
i knew all the songs and i'm like very
emotional is this an alanis morissette
theater yeah
yes
a musical it's a musical written by
diablo cody okay i didn't know about
this yes i have the bootleg link
it is incredible uh and a
director i'm working with is directing
the documentary on it well i'm also
obsessed with her like she's my
everything um and then
uh
i remember watching alan cumming who i
strongly believe is the most underrated
performance really talented no like the
most underrated performer we've got and
i think it's maybe by choice you know
that he had a fragrance called cumming
that's pretty cool is that wild great
name um i feel like i saw him in cabaret
incredible in cabaret and he did
macbeth
where he played every part in macbeth
wow every part mcduff lady macbeth he
probably doesn't know any kids either
correct
which is the key
to success at this point it seems like
not you getting better just other people
getting on the bench
so
um uh and he played every part and was
like in a bathtub like underwater
throwing himself against the wall and i
was in the fifth row i was it was a mind
bending thrill ride i was exhausted and
it was like too stressful for me because
i was like worried about him and i
couldn't understand i spend most of time
just being like how do you remember all
this
like how do you know all these words
like it stresses me out um
and then yeah i just there's something
about it like i just
the shoulders moving makes me stress
you're not a theater person it's okay i
what you're talking about is like a very
specific choreography at this point it's
basically theater i have this whole
thing
doing tv at this point like it's just
with the numbers it's basically like
doing broadway but yeah there's certain
plays i guess that i love but just like
men in
like
like a
like a broadway like janitor onesie like
makes me sad you just don't like bob
fosse
i actually he seems like a real dickhead
but i did like fosse vernon that was
excellent i loved it and i also listened
to the book on tape
that was something that like i couldn't
get enough of for a while interesting
have you seen like youtube videos of him
directing they're amazing yeah i like
things about broadway but sometimes when
i went and saw bruce springsteen here's
the other thing i just am not in the
audience very often
of things because we work at night and i
was at the bruce springsteen show
when i say
25 percent of people were texting
and then there's like rappers being open
then i it's all i can think about if i
hear one fucking
where there's original getting unwrapped
in a theater i'm like what are you doing
like i you must not go to like the walt
disney concert hall that much
i did go because there's like six layers
and like if you ever have to you know i
often i'm at the top tier and it's just
all elderly people we were there once
and some man was so old he started
falling down the steps and moshe just
helped push him up and the guy was like
don't touch me and moshe's like i just
saved your life like
very
you know the demographic at theater yes
is very old a lot of candy a lot of a
lot of
a lot of yeah
and juice there's a lot of like soup
honestly i have opening little tins
maybe i maybe i don't like the theater
anymore it does seem like a place
that would be hard to go to right now
get lost in it i can't get like sucked
into it because i other people's like
bad behavior is so distracting to me
interesting it takes all my focus um uh
the disney hall
i was frankly so disgusted by the
pattern of the carpet
that i it was like a shitty vegas hotel
carpet it was a wild choice it's like
because it like matches the seats it's
every color orange yeah it's literally
my head and i i just like couldn't wrap
my head around this gorgeous place that
all this money and this is where you you
got your
you know rugs like overstock.com you
just have to go when it's full because
then you can't see it no i i just i like
i can't
handle it um
but it that's fascinating to me that i
have a degree in theater yeah
why don't you do something why don't you
do a
podcast on i know but i don't know
um i don't know if you could tell
whitney but i'm like um i'm kind of
ramping down
i'm not trying to add another podcast a
pitch that will ramp you even further
down to have a theater criticism podcast
this will put you out of the business
this is your retirement run can i ask
you one more thing as you get
whatever do more
am i the only person where like acting
is is less appealing to me if it's not a
version of myself
you don't consider yourself a character
actress when i saw what you're saying
hated myself i loved acting and i wanted
to like be this other person and now
that i'm in a place where i'm like i
like myself like i've worked hard on
myself i'm proud of my
for the most part the way i behave i i
kind of only like to do parts that are a
extension of my personality that i don't
normally get to express because it's
socially unacceptable or it's
unattractive or shrill or whatever
i don't want to like disappear into a
holocaust survivor
i hear what you're saying i think that
don't take this the wrong way but
this is not going to be good
i'm not thin enough to play a
holocaust no no i wait i want to switch
gears i i think
well sometimes you see like
even on tick tock seeing some of these
actresses who are like in their 50s some
of the greatest broken units some of the
greatest actresses and you see them and
you're like oh like this is why you're
such a good actress you're like
a undeveloped person or you're like
there's just some i don't know something
something in some of the best actresses
i think they might be like a little like
i don't know interesting uh it's some
things like uh either they're a little
crazy or just a little orange you also
have to be in a state of childishness in
a way in a state of play you know i feel
like you've run shows you've created
shows you've created another period you
had to deal with budgets like once
you've done it's very hard
as
to kind of just be like carefree and
present in the moment because you're
like how much did this cost what time is
it like as soon as you go into your left
brain analytical brain it takes i guess
20 minutes to get back to your creative
brain to go back and forth
is very difficult and a lot of the best
actresses it's not a coincidence that
they only act yeah and i think that they
can just access it you know and a
comedian feels like a totally different
thing because we're the people that are
like what are you doing like we're the
hyper noted we're the hyper vigilant
um
caller outers
or something the critics yes but we're
also the diffusers but i do interesting
i do think though as i like
like it's because people always like how
can you do more acting the parts that
i've done recently are kind of only
like i like playing like villains and
like crazy bitches and all the things
that are already in me in a way
that i kind of just get to to
do but that i can't do in my personal
life but i've got this skill set that is
not going to use
and it makes it makes all the
brokenness not feel like it's a complete
waste or lost whitney there's room for
everyone i know but i'm just asking you
because you went to acting school and
you work so much as an actress i'm just
curious yes i would rather play an evil
bitch too you know
i think that
i think yeah i mean i i don't i think a
lot of i think we're more than that
we're more than actresses
whitney yeah uh i just think there's i
don't know i was just i was just
thinking about you and i was like oh
gosh in your background and everything
you do i was just curious where you are
what kind of parts you take these days
that you want to do i mean i think that
yes you're right you want to really
connect with it and have it be like what
is your evil twin what is the thing that
you how do you wish you could act yeah
totally i'm kind of at the point where
i'm like
like why would i want to be someone else
i'm like i like me for the i finally
like me
i don't want to like be this other thing
it's like this weird it's very sick and
very healthy at the same time i feel
like last thing i know we have to get
you out of here um
secrets uh
you hear about people's secrets do you
have any secrets
you're like last thing let's wrap this
up really quick you come out of your
belly button
whitney i'm not gonna tell you my secret
i mean it's enough to be like
about your cheating spree okay here's
the secret
when you had your
sitcom
i would drive through la and see your
face on every billboard
and just get like my blood pressure
would rise and i would just i was very
jealous that you had like your face
everywhere
never let them see you in sweatpants
while you had all these like sayings
everywhere i went i was like did she
purposely put these all over my
neighborhood
they're everywhere but they were
everywhere they weren't just in my
neighborhood but that's a secret that
has to do with you when there was a
violent did that make you backlash
against me were you still jealous i was
probably more happy then no
um i just i don't remember a violent
backlash i just remember
um
i just remember really wanting to act in
a sitcom and then i felt like
you just like came on the scene and like
had it all that's so interesting but
don't you get like you know it was like
like i was like young so i was like you
know i had a lot of like angst let me
ask you well it's interesting as someone
that's been wildly jealous of you at
many times
what
you were on chelsea sitcom
simultaneously right
right it was called chelsea are you
there chelsea yeah if it would have been
called are you there natasha maybe i
wouldn't be like you know
had high blood pressure at 27. do you
still want to do a sitcom
um
sure
why not yeah
i mean i like comedy yeah i like doing
comedy
and
do would you create one now
yeah multicam where i'm done at four it
sounds fun not if you're running out and
great again that is a lot of work yeah
you're there a lot but now the orders
are like 10 12.
oh right you would have like 30. we did
like 24 a year so i told you a secret i
was jealous of your billboards
you seemed on top of the world i was
probably
you know at the funny bone somewhere
that is
brewster tea feathers or something
rooster tea i remember rooster chief
others i'm sure you know
yeah i was getting it and it's so
interesting because i i have this like
weird instinct to like apologize and
then i have this other weird instinct to
go like oh no my life was hell i was
getting dragged on twitter by like my
heroes when you had a sitcom people were
making fun of you oh the billboards
because everything that was written in
those things were like they took my
tweets and like changed it
like they they made them they were dirty
and edgy and then they changed into like
half of all marriages and in sweatpants
like it was just like
made me it was like bad purple sitcom
font like it was just like very well i
was still jealous of them honey so yeah
no trust me and i have great taste and i
was like if i saw a billboard that was
like amanda i'd probably make fun of it
constantly too but it was like this i
remember i mean i probably made fun of
them but i was also very jealous for
sure everybody did and
i would have as well but i would go to
like events like like work events and
people would be like how you doing like
i was like people treated me like i had
a terminal illness and i didn't
understand why and people just like
don't
they're just jealous
i was like what like i didn't realize
how
despised i had sort of become and i i
just had no idea because i was in the
office all the time well you know what
you've come out on top you have a hip
podcast your house smells like a really
nice hotel i don't want to leave
and i actually want to sleep in that
guest room can i
if i ever want to like just get away
from my family i know that that's like
the whole deal is like come with your
child and like spend the night or what
not uh like i want people to come here
and like if you want to like write for a
couple hours like that's my dream
okay like please all right that would be
my dream and then
moshe can camp on the other side um okay
i love it my kid would love it here
she's
she'll um she'll think we're poor but
maybe that'll be good for her good thing
you need to like all this gold your
child just grew up looking whitney you
have a lot of gold on too okay i mean i
feel like maybe the same amount as me
this
well whatever yeah i do have a these
were gifts i did go have a ring phase
for a while all right look i saw your
gold i got jealous i will not let you
have any myself not have what you have
um
i love you i have so many more questions
but we'll have to do it another time i
want to talk about rose jokes that
didn't air
um
uh here how about when my book comes out
i'll come back please
yes okay and i'll be more
focused you've been very focused okay
this is how it is and people like it
so i don't know what to tell you
people like it even if i think that the
interview is a disaster they seem to
like it more
the worse i feel about it do you feel
bad about this interview yeah hit
episode you feel really bad about this i
just feel like i haven't seen you in so
long and there's so much i want to ask
you and i'm looking at all these
questions i didn't ask i'll come and
you'll come back spring i kept you for
three hours and then we like kind of
walked around and actually talked off
camera for a while which is very against
my nature uh we did something not
monetized and televised when we walked
around the house well your house is
gorgeous i've known you for so long you
look great thank you way better than
than when you were on the billboards 20
years ago even better i remember one
time we were in a photo shoot and they
threw me a beach ball
and i was like
and then i remember going no
like no
this and but i was dressed in a banana
costume in the commercials i was like
dancing across the football games in a
banana costume i mean it was like
valerie cherish to the max
um i don't remember that the it was bad
and embarrassing and it did make people
like hate me and never cast me in
anything for a very long time after that
like it's it's been like
a nightmare
well that show wouldn't you rather just
stay here and do your podcast esther
pavitzi said to me once like she was
like i feel like we need to revisit that
she was like i feel like you were the
first person that was cancelled it was
like what and she was like the people
were so mean to you during that time and
i was like
i feel like i just got over all that but
she was like that was crazy the way
people treated you and like how bad it
was so it was like it's i it's it's
weird it's weird i don't know
well i never know how to like respond to
that but
i think you handled it well
your
ability to like dismount is so admirable
and i just won't well i just have to
pick my kid up is this
it's like
i got here at 2 it's 5 30. yeah we have
to go i love natasha way too much
your house is amazing but you do live an
hour away from endless civilization
whitney
and 5 30 is pretty famously rush hour
the
endless honeymoon i gotta go
no i really appreciate you i adore you
and i want to just go on record saying i
have not asked you to do the podcast
because i did not want to put pressure
on you and fuck up our friendship so
thank you for doing this i'll come back
this was so fun and i'd love you to do
ours and i would love to be my dream um
and uh another period i'm gonna do an
intro that has all the other stuff but
another period if you have not seen it
you're a dumb person
so brilliant
and
so
i play a queen it's such a dream to
watch it's like you're not thinking
about phones you're not thinking about
compute like it's just like
it's a tr it's just it makes me jealous
hell yeah
so jealous when you and ricky start a tv
show a gun in my mouth
um
a night where you get to just wear
dresses all the time we did purposely do
like an era where we could just be
princesses yeah i just was like fuck i
like how did i why did i not get to do
that i mean like like like camel toe
like tight pants and then oh yeah and
like david wayne is in it like
it was an amazing show majoring in
history i would say is
the one everyone's favorite natasha
legero she's allowed me to pick up my
kid whitney i am good thank you pass i
love you i hope none of these gifts uh i
love them
expensive no i love all the bold prints
i'm gonna wear this home driving print
is not very you but they'll i love it i
really i do feel like because you're
kind of who's the woman that um got
choked by a scarf in her convertible a
dancer isabella duncan yeah i feel like
is adorable
duncan i feel like that's the only thing
i really worry about you're not the
first person to say that
i mean that is the highest compliment i
can give anyone and then my little tea
cup i mean it was really it's like for
sugar or something i love it i feel like
yeah if
if moshe ever does die you're going to
jail and it's my fault
um natasha legere we end these very
awkwardly don't write elephants love
yours
[Music]
four five
[Applause]